I was talking to my friend, I was talking, hey, good morning. I was talking to my friend. Did you just restart yourself? Still rolling. I mean, we just need a clean start. Hey, hey, hey. Hey. Hey.
我当时在跟我朋友说话，我当时在说，嘿，早上好。我正在跟我朋友说话。你刚刚把自己重启了吗？还在录着呢。我的意思是，我们只是需要一个全新的开始。嘿，嘿，嘿。嘿。嘿。
Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey.
嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。
Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey.
嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿. 嘿。嘿。嘿。
Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey. Now, Sean says that he got up at four this morning, went back to bed, and that that's his standard routine. I guess I remember you telling us about that, but what do you do when you get up at four that gets you back down?
嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。嘿。现在，肖恩说他今天早上四点就起床了，然后又回去睡觉了，说这是他的标准作息。我想我记得你跟我们说过这个，但当你四点起床时，你做什么能让自己再躺回去？
I read, I play games on my computer and anything to kind of get my brain back. So that's something you haven't been able to stop doing, right? No, for years. You don't sleep through the night. I mean, if I take something, I do. Well, what's wrong with that? I just don't want to do it all the time. You're so worried about the temple that is your body, right?
我读书，在电脑上玩游戏，做任何能让我的大脑重新运转的事情。所以这是你一直戒不掉的习惯，对吧？对，好多年了。你晚上睡不着觉。我是说，如果我吃点药的话，就能。好吧，那有什么不好的？我只是不想一直这么做。你这么在意你这具形同圣殿的身体，对吧？
You don't want to put anything nasty inside there. Yeah, nothing to mix with the other crap authority. You don't wanna scoop the mac and cheese gut by now. You're bamboo shoot healthy body. Sean, how would you describe your body? Cause I'll go first. Cause somebody asked me to describe Sean's body and right off the top, I said pigs in a blanket.
你可不想往里面塞什么恶心的东西。对，别跟别的垃圾权威混在一起。你现在可不想舀什么通心粉和奶酪的肚子。你可是竹笋健康体。肖恩，你会怎么形容你的身体？因为我先来。因为有人让我形容肖恩的身体，我脱口而出，就说毯子里的猪。
How would you? You know what's so funny? That's what came to. I was watching the Bill Maher show the other night and some of the guests got on and Bill said, gosh, you've lost so much weight. And he goes, yeah, there's nothing worse than a skinny guy with a pot belly.
你会怎么……你知道最搞笑的是什么吗？我也是这么想的。我前几天晚上在看比尔·马赫的节目，有几个嘉宾上去了，比尔说，天哪，你瘦了这么多。然后他说，对啊，没有什么比一个瘦子顶着个啤酒肚更糟糕的了。
And I raised my hand and Scotty was like, yep. No, I don't see you as that. You know me neither. You guys have, I mean, I could get there. I could get there. You have a very nice proportional frame. It's true. How big you think you could get, Sean? I wanted to get so big when I was younger. I wanted to get like, I would go to the gym all the time. I'd drink milkshakes. My oldest brother would make like make would take me out for burgers.
然后我举起了手，斯科蒂就像是在说，没错。不，我不觉得你是那样的。你知道我也不觉得。你们有，我是说，我可以达到那种状态。我可以达到那种状态。你有一个比例非常好的骨架。确实。肖恩，你觉得你能长多壮？我年轻的时候特别想长得那么壮。我以前总是去健身房。我喝奶昔。我老大以前会带我去吃汉堡。
And I would constantly, constantly eat. I just couldn't gain a pound. Well, it was like what? Like what? How'd that pan out? Did it give you, did you get the look you were looking for? Well, hundreds and hundreds of years ago, that was a sign of power, right?
而且我一直在吃，一直在吃。我就是一磅都胖不起来。好吧，那就像是，什么？就像什么？结果怎么样？它给了你，你得到了你想要的造型吗？好吧，在几百年几百年以前，那是权力的象征，对吧？
Exactly. You would be a big and huge and sort of a glutton, right? Yeah. Yeah, so if you were thin, what? You had no power? Yeah. You, so if you were thin, what? You had no power? Yeah. You were, you were probably. It was a sign of, yeah, it was a,
没错。你会变得又大又壮，而且有点像个饕餮，对吧？对。对，所以如果你很瘦，那又怎样？你没有权力？对。你，所以如果你很瘦，那又怎样？你没有权力？对。你曾经，你可能。那是……的象征，对，那是一个，
if you were kind of bigger, it was a sign of prosperity. Well, right. Yeah. Prosperity. Well, here's something that happened to me yesterday. I was at the car wash. There you are.
如果你体型比较大，那是繁荣的象征。嗯，对。对，繁荣。好吧，昨天发生了一件事。我在洗车行。你来了。
And the, I threw my stuff. You like to ride through? You like one of those? No, no. I do that with the kids every once in a while. Oh, you do for real? It's fun. Yeah, it's fun.
然后，我把我的东西……你喜欢开车穿过去洗吗？你喜欢那种吗？不，不。我偶尔会跟孩子们一起那样。哦，你真的会去？挺好玩的。对，挺好玩的。
No, this guy is like, you gotta go to the wash. That's what I call, by the way, good clean fun. Good clean weekend fun. No, so I- The car wash is good clean fun. No, we get the quotes out of the way. No you didn't. Thank you.
不，这家伙就像，你得去洗车。顺便说一句，我把这叫做干净又好玩的乐趣。美好的周末干净乐趣。不，所以，洗车是干净又好玩的乐趣。不，我们把那些台词抛到脑后吧。你才没有。谢谢。
Go ahead, Sean. Go ahead, Sean, back to Sean. No, so I get it hand washed, right? So I'm sitting there, oh, look at this. Hold your jokes. Hold your jokes, Will. Boom. God, look, he's just, oh, we heard hand.
说吧，肖恩。说吧，肖恩，回到肖恩。不，所以我让人手洗车，对吧？所以我坐在那儿，哦，看这个。收起你的笑话。收起你的笑话，威尔。砰。天哪，看，他只是，哦，我们听到手洗了。
Time for a H.J. joke. Fucking clown. Go ahead, Sean. Fuck. So I gave my car away for a hand wash. I come sit down, I'm waiting, and I threw my stuff in the trash, right? When you clean your car up before they wash it.
是时候开个手淫笑话了。他妈的小丑。说吧，肖恩。操。所以我把车送去手洗。我坐下来，等着，然后我把东西扔进了垃圾桶，对吧？当你洗车前把车里清理干净的时候。
And all of them consist, you know, there's a lot of near full bottles of water. And so I was sitting there because I didn't think I was gonna be thirsty. 20 minutes later, I'm like, God, I'm kind of thirsty. So I'll go back to the trash and pulled out one of the bottled water. I hope someone took a picture of that.
而且所有的都包括，你知道的，有很多几乎没喝完的水瓶。所以我坐在那儿，因为我以为我不口渴。20分钟后，我想，天哪，我有点口渴。所以我回到垃圾桶旁，抽出一瓶水。我希望有人拍下那个画面。
And a woman just stared at me like, I was, there's something wrong with me. And I was conflicted. I was like, do I care what she thinks? Do I not care what she thinks? And I cared what she thought. So I looked at her, I said, I threw my bottle out prematurely.
然后一个女人就这样盯着我，就像我是，我有什么毛病一样。我很纠结。我想，我在乎她怎么想吗？我不在乎她怎么想吗？我还在乎她的想法。所以我看着她，我说，我刚才太早把瓶子扔了。
And she said, oh my God. She's just got crazier at her eyes. She goes, aren't you afraid it's dirty? I said, no, it wasn't touching anything bad. And so she just glared at me. You were in a conversation. Yeah. Wait, that was the end of it?
她说，哦，天哪。她眼里的疯狂劲儿更浓了。她说，你不怕它脏吗？我说，不，它没接触什么不好的东西。然后她就瞪着我。你们在对话。等等，就这完了？
That was the whole thing. She just ended up staring at me and I drank it. Would you ever do that? We have to go back and- Yeah, it makes- Fuck, man, I don't even know where to attack that story. It's just, every part of it is just open for assassination. I mean-
这就完了。她最后就一直盯着我，然后我把水喝了。你会那样做吗？我们得回去……操，伙计，我甚至不知道该从哪里开始吐槽这个故事。简直是，每一部分都毫无防备，任人宰割。我是说——
Wait, so was your water bottle slaying already filled with a bottle? Why didn't you just put that thing right in your little water bottle purse and just go sit down and wait for your car to be done? You've got one of those, right? No, because I threw them out thinking, oh, I don't need them.
等等，所以你的水瓶座言论已经装满了一个瓶子？你为什么不直接把那东西放进你的小水瓶包里，然后坐下来等你的车洗完呢？你有一个那种包，对吧？不，因为我把它们扔了，心想，哦，我不需要它们了。
And there was a little water left in them. So then sitting there, I was like, oh, I'm kind of thirsty actually. So I went back into the trash. I love it. You don't want to use a glass water left in them. So I'm then sitting there. I was like, oh, I'm kind of thirsty actually. So I went back into the trash. I love it. You don't want to use a glass bottle that's reusable. How fucking dare you? Or a metal one.
里面还剩了一点水。所以我坐在那儿，我想，哦，其实我有点口渴。所以我又回到了垃圾桶里。我太喜欢了。你不想用一个可以重复使用的玻璃水瓶吗？你怎么敢？或者一个金属的。
Oh, Sean, let me just say something. I need to get like a water bottle. That is to me the height of privilege. We're opening up a plastic water bottle. Okay. The height of joke. A visual joke for our radio audience. It's not fair.
哦，肖恩，让我说句话。我得弄个像样的水瓶。对我来说，那是特权的巅峰。我们正在打开一个塑料水瓶。好吧。笑话的巅峰。给我们的广播听众看个视觉笑话。这不公平。
Well, anyway, enough about that. Are we getting to the guest? Oh, no, no, you don't wanna do another hour on that. All right, so, Will, what did you get into last night? Last night I got into nothing much. It was pretty chill. It was kids, it was movie night for the little guys. Every night is movie night.
好吧，不管怎样，闲话少说。我们要切入嘉宾了吗？哦，不，不，你可不想在这上面再花一个小时。好吧，那么，威尔，你昨晚干嘛去了？昨晚我没干啥。挺放松的。是孩子们，是小家伙们的电影之夜。每天晚上都是电影之夜。
Did you watch the movie with them? Yeah, but they kind of, last night we ended up watching the classic Peter Pan. And so what they'll do is they'll go. So we're talking about the little boys, not the big boys. So they'll go, we wanna watch Pinocchio. And I'm like, okay, so you put it on, right?
你跟他们一起看电影了吗？对，但他们有点……昨晚我们最后看的是经典电影《彼得·潘》。所以他们会做的是……所以我们说的是小男孩，不是大男孩。所以他们会说，我们想看《木偶奇遇记》。我说，好吧，那你把它放上，对吧？
We put it on in our room. They come in, they call it movie night, sort of 20 minutes before their bedtime. And then they don't really watch. What they really want to do is they want to be flipped on the bed and thrown into the pillows. Yeah, I get it. Like, Demi, Demi will actually, he'll just look at you
我们在房间里放了这部片子。他们走进来，管这叫电影之夜，大约在他们睡觉前20分钟。然后他们根本不怎么看。他们真正想做的是被翻到床上，扔进枕头堆里。对，我懂。就像，黛米，黛米实际上，他会看着你
and go, can you throw me please? And you go, oh yeah, okay. But doesn't get them all fired up and then they can't go to bed? No, as it turns out, and you can look it up, as it turns out that kind of activity, getting thrown around and getting sort of squeezed and stuff, it gets a lot of like nervous energy out
然后说，你能把我扔过去吗？你会说，哦，好吧，行。但这不会让他们兴奋过度然后睡不着觉吗？不，事实证明，你可以去查查，事实证明，这种活动，被抛来抛去，还有被挤压什么的，会释放很多神经能量
and they end up falling asleep. And it's been, Oh really? Yeah, it's been about. Maybe I need to try that, so I can. Yeah, Scotty, Scotty, throw you around a little. Maybe you choke me out. No, hey, will you throw me?
然后他们最后就睡着了。而且一直是，哦真的吗？对，已经差不多了。也许我也得试试那个，这样我就可以……对，斯科蒂，斯科蒂把你扔来扔去。也许你把我勒晕。不，嘿，你能把我扔过去吗？
I'll throw you, for sure. Hey, what about, have you ever gotten real close to accidentally really hurting one of your kids doing that? I mean, it's like, and trampolines, by the way. Forget it. Yeah, maple wants one. Honey, no, you're just gonna get better and better and better at it, meaning you're gonna be flipping yourself
我肯定把你扔过去。嘿，话说回来，你有没有在做那种事的时候，差一点就不小心真的弄伤了其中一个孩子？我是说，就像蹦床一样，顺便说一句。别提了。对，枫树想要一个。亲爱的，不，你只会在这方面变得越来越熟练，这意味着你会把自己翻得
higher and higher and doing more revolutions, and then it doesn't end well. Yeah, it's the trampoline. We have one, we have one. We have a little house out on Long Island, New York State. Next to the bowling alley. And we have a trampoline. And now of course it's injured.
越来越高，做更多的旋转，然后结果就不会太好了。对，就是蹦床。我们有一个，我们有一个。我们在纽约州长岛有一个小房子。在保龄球馆旁边。我们有一个蹦床。现在当然它已经坏了。
I'm gonna say six winters and it's real rusty. You've seen it. It's always covered in debris. And I'm so stupid. I let the kids are like, we're going out. I'm like, okay. And I'm just, it's just, it's gonna be a moment. There's gonna be somebody come back
我得说经历了六个冬天，而且真的很生锈。你见过的。它总是盖满了碎屑。而我太蠢了。我让孩子们就像，我们要出去了。我说，好吧。我只是，这会是一个时刻。会有人回来
and go my arms backwards. Yeah, I can't. I know, I know. It's just going the pool, kids. I know. How fun was Sunday? Okay, here, ready? Sunday was super fun.
然后说我的胳膊断了。对，我不能。我知道，我知道。孩子们，去泳池吧，我懂。星期天多好啊。好吧，准备好了吗？星期天超级棒。
You guys, you may be noticing a pattern with our guests lately. They're a lot cooler than we are. And my guest today is no exception. We're getting right into the intro. Before becoming an Academy Award winning actor, he made his acting debut alongside his mother in an East Village improv show at age 10.
你们大家，可能最近已经注意到我们嘉宾的一个规律了。他们比我们要酷得多。我今天的嘉宾也不例外。我们直接进入开场白。在成为奥斯卡奖得主演员之前，他在10岁时就在东村的一场即兴表演中与母亲同台完成了他的演艺首秀。
As a teen, he dabbled in break dancing to impress the girls, Tito, the break dancing part. And then he played head thug in the 1990s, 1990s Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles movie. But I think he's done just a few things since then. I'll have to ask him It's one of my favorite actors of all time Sam Rockwell Sammy's all healed up I'm so sorry you had to wait a really long time for that. No, that was amazing. I was fantastic
十几岁时，他为了给女孩留下深刻印象而涉足霹雳舞，蒂托，就是霹雳舞那部分。然后他在20世纪90年代的《忍者神龟》电影中扮演了头号恶棍。但我想他从那以后还做过不少别的事。我得问问他。他是我的所有演员中最喜欢的之一，山姆·洛克威尔。萨米，你完全康复了吗？真对不起，你为了这个等了那么久。不，那太棒了。我太棒了。
Listener our our guest today had an illness. What, a few weeks ago? I did. I did. I had some sort of neurovirus or something, whatever makes lots of poop come out of you. Right. And you had to pull the handbrake day out.
听众朋友们，我们今天的嘉宾生病了。什么，几周前？是的。是的。我得了某种诺如病毒之类的东西，就是那种让你拉很多大便的东西。对。而你不得不紧急踩下刹车。
Yeah, and so what he did was, I had a temperature. And he doesn't know that it's a surprise guest situation. So he texted each one of us individually, or at least me, and said, hey man. It takes a Jason, yeah. No, I think it started with just a picture of a thermometer.
是的，所以他做的是，我发烧了。而且他不知道这是一个有神秘嘉宾的情况。所以他给每个人分别发了信息，或者至少给我发了，说，嘿，兄弟。需要一个杰森，对。不，我想它是从一张温度计的照片开始的。
And you know, Sam, and Sam, we're gonna let you talk in a second. But listen, you need to know that Sam, one of his things that he's very famous for is sending pictures of really life-scarring images. And I thought, what could this, okay, so what could this thermometer be? It must be a rectal thermometer coming from Sam.
你知道，山姆，山姆，我们一会儿再让你说话。但是听着，你需要知道山姆，他最出名的事情之一就是发送一些真正会在视觉上留下心理创伤的图片。我想，这会是什么，好吧，那这个会是什么温度计？这一定是一个来自山姆的直肠温度计。
So I didn't really respond. And then a couple of days later, he said something like, yeah, listen, man, I'm still sick. I'm not going to be able to make it. I'm like, hey, Sam, I think you meant to send this to somebody else who might be waiting for you to show up somewhere. And he should just know you sent it to the wrong person.
所以我没有真正回复。然后几天后，他说了一些类似的话，是的，听着，兄弟，我还是生病了。我没法去了。我说，嘿，山姆，我想你是想把这个发给别人，那个人可能正等着你在某个地方出现。他应该知道你发错人了。
He's like, was I not supposed to be on your podcast today? I'm like, oh, so you were surprised. I blew it. But that didn't matter. Will didn't know and Jason didn't know when you were gonna come on, so it's fine. That's right, that's right. Still a surprise to all of us.
他说，我今天不应该上你的播客吗？我说，哦，所以你很惊讶。我搞砸了。但这没关系，威尔不知道，杰森也不知道你什么时候来，所以没关系。没错，没错。对我们所有人来说仍然是个惊喜。
Hey guys. It's so good to see you, Sam. Thank you for being here today. It's so cool to see you guys, man. One of my favorite. And are you doing the same Jason Bateman thing because of a part? Were you calling all the Spatial Hero?
嘿，伙计们。很高兴见到你，山姆。谢谢你今天能来。很高兴见到你们，伙计。我最喜欢的之一。你是因为一个角色也在做和杰森·贝特曼一样的事情吗？你当时在给所有《空间英雄》打电话吗？
Yeah. I am, I'm doing something in April, right? Sort of look like. Yeah, me too, April 15th. I got it, but you grew up in the same part. You grew up in Mansbeard, yeah, what was the same part? You grew up in Mansbeard. Mine's...
对。我是，我四月份要做点什么，对吧？看起来有点像。对，我也是，4月15日。我懂，但你们在同一个地方长大。你在曼斯伯德长大，对，在同一个地方吗？你在曼斯伯德长大。我的是……
Well, how long has that been? How long you got on that? About six years. No, um, this is, this is, uh, this is about some hair and makeup. You might need to go into the trailer. But my guy's supposed to kind of be a real loser and, and is capable of that part, but get to the beard. Yeah. I got another month left.
好吧，这有多久了？你留这个多久了？大约六年。不，嗯，这是，这是，嗯，这是为了发型和化妆。你可能得去化妆车里看看。但我的角色应该是个真正的失败者，并且能够胜任那个角色，不过说到胡子。对。我还有一个多月。
Sammy, thanks for being here. Tell me, I want to get into all of it, but I want to know about the break dancing thing. Yeah. Well, that was bad break dancing. But I remember years ago, I saw you do the splits in center of life. I was like, is that really him?
萨米，谢谢你能来。告诉我，我想了解所有的事，但我特别想知道霹雳舞的事。好吧。好吧，那是个糟糕的霹雳舞。但我记得多年前，我看到你在《生活中心》表演一字马。我当时想，那是他本人吗？
Was that really you? Yeah, I did it. I did, I tore my hamstring doing it during full for love actually eight times a week. Wow. Wow, full for love is great. We did it. It was a bit in the play. Yeah, yeah. It's not, you got to be warm. You did the full on splits? You know, it's a cheat. It's a cheat. I don't know if it's the risky business or the James Brown, but you're kind of like,
真的是你吗？对，我做的。我做了，我为了爱，每周演八场《爱之针》，在做那个动作时拉伤了我的腿筋。哇。哇，《爱之针》太棒了。我们演了。那是剧里的一段。对，对。这不行，你得先热身。你做了完全的一字马？你知道，这算是个作弊。算是个作弊。我不知道那是《乖仔也疯狂》还是詹姆斯·布朗，但你有点像是，
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Careful. You know, it's not quite... Yeah, careful. It's not quite the split splits. But have you always been able to kind of do that? You always been a bit of a dancer? I kind of messed around.
哦，对，对，对。小心。你知道，那并不完全是……对，小心。那并不完全是一字马。但你一直都能做那种动作吗？你一直都有点舞蹈功底吗？我随便练过。
I watched, I remember watching James Brown and watching Michael Jackson. I was in the, it was a way to meet girls when I was 12. And I guess I watched Risky Business and tried to imitate that. Now, but then the great limited series that you did with all the, with the Fosse burden. Yeah, you don't just sort of train for that.
我看着，我记得我看过詹姆斯·布朗，看过迈克尔·杰克逊。我在，那是我12岁时结识女孩的一种方式。我想我看了《乖仔也疯狂》，并试着模仿那个。现在，还有你拍的那部包含所有，带有福斯风格的精彩限定剧。对，你不能随随便便就为那个进行训练。
You need to be somewhat gifted before you even consider taking that part on. So you know what you're doing on the dance floor. Yeah. Well, thanks, thanks. But that was the first formal training. I did I think on that thing How much dancing you doing these days man? Hey cool it bro. He's I'm just Cool it I know it's true what you guys are in g-force together. Yeah, yeah, what a cast by the way
在你考虑接下那个角色之前，你必须具备一定的天赋。所以你知道自己在舞池里在做什么。好吧，谢谢，谢谢。但那是那次我接受的第一次正规训练。这些日子你跳舞多吗，兄弟？嘿，冷静点，兄弟。他，我只是……冷静点，我知道，你们俩一起演过《G力量》，对吧？对，对，顺便说一句，这演员阵容太强大了。
What a cast Zach. Galvanakis, Bill Nye. Yeah, Bill Nye, that's right. That's right. Heck of a cast. So Sam, when you were a kid, San Francisco, right? I love San Francisco. Yeah, yeah.
什么演员阵容啊。扎克·加利凡纳基斯，比尔·奈伊。对，比尔·奈伊，没错。没错。真是一套豪华阵容。所以山姆，当你还是个孩子的时候，在旧金山，对吧？我爱旧金山。对，对。
In the city or just like in the Bay Area? In the city proper, yeah, moved on. Wow, and your parents were both actors too. Yeah, and my father was a union rep for the supermarket clerks and the printers. And we lived all, we lived everywhere. Phil Moore, Tenderloin, Castro. I met Harvey Milk when I was eight years old.
在市区还是就在湾区？在真正的市区，对，搬来搬去的。哇，你的父母也都演员。对，我父亲是超市店员和印刷工的工会代表。我们住过所有地方，我们到处搬。菲尔莫尔，田德隆区，卡斯特罗区。我八岁时见过哈维·米尔克。
He was getting in the unions and stuff. That's wild. Yeah, my dad was a big union guy. Couldn't cross a picket line. And do you think that San Francisco had more of an artistic community or as much of an artistic community as New York? Or was it different or what's the difference?
他当时正在参与工会之类的事。太疯狂了。对，我爸爸是个坚定的工会分子。绝不跨过纠察线。你觉得旧金山比纽约有更多的艺术氛围，或者有和纽约一样多的艺术氛围吗？还是说不一样？有什么区别？
It wasn't as cool. I wanted to go to the Fame School. I went to sort of a small school of the arts in San Francisco. I went to high school with Margaret Cho, Ayesha Tyler. Wow. Me and Ayesha dated for a while.
它没那么酷。我想去名气学校。我去了旧金山的一个小艺术学校。我和玛格丽特·曹、艾莎·泰勒一起上高中。哇。我和艾莎约会过一段时间。
And we were in a very terrible improvisational troupe called Batwing Lubricant. That is fat. We did that in rough. We performed at the other cafe, which is a famous place. Wow. So what age are we at now when when the acting bug starts to take hold? Well, I was 10, I dabbled with it. And then I was sort of busy
我们曾在一个非常糟糕的即兴表演剧团里，叫“蝙蝠翼润滑剂”。太逊了。我们在Rough演过。我们在The Other Cafe演出过，那是一个著名的地方。哇。那么当表演的萌芽开始扎根时，我们多大了？嗯，我10岁时，稍微涉猎了一下。然后我大概都在忙着
getting stoned and trying to meet girls. And then I didn't take acting very seriously. And it was kind of a rough school mac and tear. But we had the soda kids within that, like about 500 of them within the 2000. And juvenile hall was across the street. So it was like a mixture of kids from the mission. There were rich kids coming in for the School of the Arts. And I was dating a dancer and it was around 16.
抽大麻和试图结识女孩。然后我并没有把表演当回事。而且那是个有点粗糙的学校，马克·泰勒。但我们在那里面有大约500个像这样的小孩，总共2000人。少年管教所在街对面。所以那里就像是米慎区的孩子，还有为了艺术学校而来的有钱小孩的混合体。我当时在和一个舞者约会，那大约是我16岁的时候。
I was kind of dabbling in it but I didn't take it seriously. Well and then when did it get serious? Did you move out of there? Did you go to New York? I got a movie when I was 18 and then I moved to New York and I didn't really get so I do like you know toothpaste commercials and shit like that and then I I studied with William Esper when I was 23. Sure. I did two years with him and then I met my acting coach there,
我当时只是在涉猎，但并没有把它当回事。好吧，那是什么时候开始认真的？你从那里搬出去了吗？你去了纽约吗？我18岁时拍了一部电影，然后我搬到了纽约，我并没有真正去拍，你知道的，牙膏广告之类的破事，然后我23岁时跟威廉·埃斯珀学习。当然。我和他一起度过了两年，然后我在那里遇到了我的表演教练，
Terry Nickerbacher. Oh, wow. And studied in Meisner. Yeah. Wow. Now, why was the move to New York instead of Los Angeles? Shorter drive, more opportunity? Yeah, I guess my mom lived there.
特里·尼克尔巴克。哦，哇。并在梅斯纳尔体系下学习。对。哇。现在，为什么是搬到纽约而不是洛杉矶？车程更短，机会更多？对，我想我妈妈住在那里。
And so I thought that was the place to go. And I kind of romanticized being a struggling actor, because I'd seen my mom do it. And a free place to stay, maybe it and a free place to stay maybe And a free place to stay but I love that story you told in your acceptance speech when you want one you ask her Yeah, sorry. I just hold it because we are gonna put we're gonna put a pause in use mine sure But dude so you win an Oscar you tell that great story about going to the movies with your dad And I loved yeah that with the way and I'm just going I literally just remember about going to the movies with your dad and I loved that with the way, and I'm just going, I literally just remember it
所以我觉得那是该去的地方。而且我对作为一个苦苦挣扎的演员有一种浪漫化的幻想，因为我见过我妈妈那样做。而且有个免费的地方住，也许它……有个免费的地方住也许它……有个免费地方住，但我喜欢你在获奖感言中讲的那个故事，当你赢了的时候你问她……对，抱歉。我只是拿着它，因为我们要把，我们要暂停一下，用我的一定可以。但是兄弟，所以你赢得了奥斯卡，你讲了那个关于和你爸爸一起去电影院的精彩故事，我喜欢，对，那个方式，我只是在说，我真的只记得
because it was so impactful that your dad would take you out of school and he'd lie to the school saying that you had to do some shit or somebody died. Yeah, that my grandmother passed away. Again. It's pretty morbid isn't it? That's so good. That's so great.
因为它太震撼了，你爸爸会把你从学校接走，他对学校撒谎说你必须去处理一些破事或者有人去世了。对，说我奶奶去世了。又来一次。这挺病态的对吧？太棒了。太棒了。
Fucking the best man. Yeah, I mean. I was in music camp when I was a kid and I sent a letter to my mom saying can you please come pick me up? Please just tell him grandpa died, please Just tell them grandpa died and you have to pick me up. She never did. She never did. Yeah And did you love it? Did you love getting pulled out of school going to the movies? Or did you want to stay in school and hang out with your buddies? No, I loved it. I loved it
他妈的太棒了，兄弟。对，我是说。我小时候在音乐夏令营，我给我妈写了一封信，说你能来接我吗？求求你告诉他们爷爷去世了，求求你告诉他们爷爷去世了，你必须来接我。她从来没来。她从来没来。对。你喜欢吗？你喜欢被从学校接走去看电影吗？还是你想留在学校和你的死党们鬼混？不，我喜欢。我喜欢。
Yeah, the school I was in at the time. I think I was getting beat up a lot. It was kind of a rough school Yeah, you were like in fight. I read you beat up a lot. It was kind of a rough school. Yeah, you were like in fight. I read you were in a lot of fights or the white supremacists. Yeah, but I didn't win any of the fights. I was getting my ass kicked. And then my dad, yeah, so when my dad took me out,
对，我当时上的那所学校。我想我经常挨打。那是个有点粗糙的学校。对，你好像在打架。我读到你经常挨打。那是个有点粗糙的学校。对，你好像在打架。我读到你卷入了许多打架或者白人至上主义者的事情。对，但我一场架也没赢。我一直在挨屁股。然后我爸，对，所以当我爸把我接走时，
I was like, yeah, let's get the hell out of here. And then thank God, grandma was alive. And then we went to the opening day of Rocky. Oh, God. Really? Nobody had heard of it. My dad took me to all of those movies during that time too. They were so good.
我就想，太好了，咱们赶紧离开这鬼地方吧。谢天谢地，奶奶还活着。然后我们去看了《洛基》的首映日。哦，天哪。真的吗？没人听说过它。我爸在那期间也带我看了所有那些电影。它们太棒了。
All those movies that none of my friends were seeing. But like, my friends weren't going in to see like the Werner Herzog documentary, you know? Or like any movies with subtitles. No. Yeah. I remember my mom would take me too. I was kind of like her movie
所有那些我朋友都没看过的电影。就像，我的朋友们才不会去看那种沃纳·赫尔佐格的纪录片，你知道的？或者任何带字幕的电影。不。对。我记得我妈也会带我去。我有点像是她的电影
powder. I remember her taking me to see, was it Missing, the one with Sissy's Basic and Jack Lomond. Yeah. And Jack Lomond. Yeah. About the people going Missing and Chillate. I was 11.
小跟班。我记得她带我去看了，是《失踪》吗？就是西席·斯派塞克和杰克·莱蒙演的那部。对，还有杰克·莱蒙。对。关于人们在智利失踪的事。我当时11岁。
How long have you saw that? 11. Pretty heavy. Sure. Couldn't see for months. I saw the Deer Hunter, I was 10. I saw like Taxi Driver when I was eight. Exactly.
你多大看到那个的？11岁。挺沉重的。当然。几个月都看不见。我看《猎鹿人》时10岁。我8岁就看过《出租车司机》。没错。
Right? It's like, got you excited about movies, but it makes you grow up quick. But there's something there, okay, so, but there is something there, messaging wise, which is like, you don't want to take your kids to just see something that's got gratuitous violence or language or whatever,
对吧？就像，让你对电影感到兴奋，但也让你成熟得很快。但这里面有些东西，好吧，所以，但这里面在传达信息方面确实有些东西，那就是，你不想只带孩子们去看那些只有无故暴力、脏话或其它什么的东西，
but if it's great filmmaking, and it's a great story, and it's a great, and it's great art, then there's value in that. The violence can be done cinematically. Yeah, but I mean, people enjoy the other thing. I was on a plane once, I saw a guy watch Fast and Furious movies with the sound off. I'm just saying, so there's something for everybody. Right.
但如果这是一部伟大的电影制作，是一个伟大的故事，是一个伟大的，是一门伟大的艺术，那么这其中就有价值。暴力可以以电影化的方式来呈现。对，但我的意思是，人们也喜欢别的东西。我曾在飞机上看到一个人关着声音看《速度与激情》电影。我只是说，所以每个人都有适合自己的东西。对。
That is when you've had the full lobotomy. Yeah. That's when they took it all out. They just scraped it clean. Wait, Sam, so I also read you hurt your hands or something, was that from fighting? I heard no, it was a car accident. Yeah.
那就是你已经做过完全额叶切除术的时候。对。那是他们把一切都切除的时候。他们只是把它刮干净了。等等，山姆，所以我也听说你伤了手什么的，那是打架造成的吗？我听说不，是一场车祸。对。
What? Wait, wait, is that fully extended? Oh, wait, do it again. Can you not, oh yeah, you can straighten them out. Oh, look at that. Wow. Oh, the ginger. The ginger's almost my god. You see it in the green mile for a second. Yeah Yeah, that character, but I usually has got so he has a tweak tip of of what the Yeah, they were all crushed. Yeah, four of them were crushed. What happened?
什么？等等，那是完全伸直的吗？哦，等等，再做一次。你不能，哦对，你能把它们拉直。哦，看那个。哇。哦，姜汁。这姜汁简直快要……我的天。你在《绿里奇迹》里看到过它一秒钟。对，对，那个角色，但是通常他的手指有一个微调的尖端，什么样的……对，它们全都被压碎了。对，有四个被压碎了。发生了什么？
I flipped a Jeep Cherokee on Sunset and La Brea. Just fucking got into a squat. You just flipped it? on Sunset and La Brea. Just fucking got into a squat and you just flipped it? Oh, you were in it. That's right. I'm fucking strong. You used your legs. I started the Roy's really early. That'd be so good if you were like driving around
我在日落大道和拉布雷亚大道把一辆吉普切诺基给翻了。就他妈的一个深蹲。你把它翻了？在日落大道和拉布雷亚大道。就他妈的一个深蹲，然后你就把它翻了？哦，你在车里。没错。我他妈强壮得很。你用了你的腿。我起步得很早。如果你开车的时候，看到洛克威尔，然后你会想，他在翻一辆车吗？那太酷了。所以等等，日落大道和拉布雷亚大道，听起来像是，所以你在那里的街角买汉堡时对……我当时，我压了一点点，你知道下雨后路面变得有点油腻的那种……对，我躺在那条路上，我车速有点快地撞上了。我当时想在一个女孩面前表现一下。嗯，她一直在看着。我拐了个弯，然后我开始打滑。
then you just see Rockwell and you're like, is he flipping a fucking car? So wait, Sunset and La Brea, that sounds like, so you were upset at the Fat Burger there on the corner when you were getting you. I was, I hit the lead a little, little you know after rains when it gets kind of oily Yeah, I lay that the roads and I hit the I hit the leg kind of fast. I was trying to impress a girl Mm-hmm, and she kept going I took a left turn and I got into a skin
我从打滑中恢复过来，但接着我撞上了马路牙子。然后我“啪”的一声。操，伙计。你在纽约会想念开车吗？不，我一点也不想念开车。不，我开，我在电影里开车。
I got out of the skin that just went but those models I think tended to yeah pretty easily their tippers wait You're a model you're still you talking about, the car or the girl? The chick, the chick, the girl. Walk me back, you're trying to impress a girl at the stop light that you don't know. Okay, okay. I'm trying to like do like an American graffiti, kind of hit the lead kind of thing.
但那就像个电子游戏。对，那是真的。我曾经不得不在电影里开车，那个场景是，我开着一辆在高速公路上逆行的车，他们做的是在车顶上搭建了这样一个舱，里面有一个特技演员，手里拿着一个方向盘在控制方向，
Sure. And, but then I took a left and I got into a skid. Then I got out of the skid, but then I hit the curb. And I went, psh. Fuck, man. Do you miss driving being in New York? No, and I miss driving at all. No, I drive, I drive in movies.
这样他或她就能做出所有正确的转弯。他们不依赖演员去左转、右转，去配合迎面开来、他们已经规划好左转右转的车流。那是我经历过的最可怕的事情，我以错误的方向在路上超速行驶。因为你无法掌控。我无法掌控，但看起来好像我在掌控，
Yeah. But that's like a video game. Yeah, that's true. I once had to drive in a movie and the scene was, I was driving a car that was going the wrong way on a freeway and what they did was they built one of these pods on top of the car where they have a stunt driver up there with a wheel that is steering the car
我转动了方向盘，但车顶上的一个小巧的内置舱里有一个家伙。就在几个小时前。这听起来对我很棒，这听起来有点……但它管用。如果你有控制欲，尤其是……我有点想赛车。还有其他人想赛车吗？
so that he or she can make all the correct turns. They're not relying on an actor to go left, go right in coordination with the cars coming at you, going left and right that they've worked out. It was the most horrific thing I've ever been through where I'm speeding the wrong way on the road. Cause you're not in control. I'm not in control, but looking as if I am,
我甚至不是在开玩笑。你真的想赛车吗？我确实挺想尝试一次的。你知道吗，伙计们，为了我的生日，这就是我想要的。我不是在开玩笑。你真的想？我可以安排。对，我们可以去柳泉赛道。
I've turned to my wheel, but there's a dude up on top of the roof in a little tiny built pod. Just a couple of hours earlier. That sounds great to me, that sounds kind of. But it worked. If you have control issues, especially... I kind of want to race cars. Does anybody else want to race cars?
我没开玩笑。杰森，他妈的赢过一次。我们聊过这个。杰森在那儿赢过三次。我知道，我想试试。你赛过车，杰森？我是说，在名人赛里，但我确实有两种车。
I'm not even kidding. Do you really want to race cars? I do kind of want to just try it once. You know, guys, for my birthday, that's what I want. I'm not kidding. Do you really? I can set that up. Yeah, we can go up to Willow Springs.
不，你在波科诺的一场真正的比赛中把车翻了。对，精确地说。职业生涯参加了两场比赛。然后我车底朝天了，然后我说，好吧，我好了。哇。我还是回去搞名人那一套吧。巴斯·芬德在那样做，对吧？他，但他在做真正真正的比赛，比如
I'm not kidding. Jason, fucking one. We've talked about it. Jason's won that thing three times. I know, I want to try it. You've raced cars, Jason? I mean, in a celebrity race, but then I did have two kind of cars.
宝马和欧洲各地的那些。对。哇。那是一个山姆。我想回到你这里。我想回到你刚开始的时候。我在百老汇演出。当然。我在舞台上演出。我迫不及待地想谈谈戏剧和所有这些。嘿，对。对。对。山姆，舞台上发生过什么有趣的事吗？有人忘过台词吗？
No, you flipped a car in a real race in the Poconos. Yeah, exactly. What was professional for two races. And then I got upside down and said, okay, I'm good. Wow. I'll go back to the celeb stuff. Bass Fender is doing that, right? He's, but he's doing the real, real race is like
我从没见过肖恩跳过我想去百老汇的话题。我从没见过他像那样说，我们会讲到那里的。我们能听听肖恩在塔巴斯科演的那部小戏吗？哦，塔巴斯科。他在里面难道不是火辣得要命吗？哦。
BMWs and shit across Europe. Yeah. Wow. That's a Sam. I want to get back to you. I want to get back to you when you're at the beginning. I do it on Broadway. Sure. I do it on the boards. I can't wait to just talk theater and all that. Hey, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sam, anything ever funny ever happened on stage? Anyone ever forget a line?
奥斯卡。你太好了，山姆，能来。这对我很重要。这意义重大。那是，等等，但说真的，听着，我对你们所有人和《黑钱胜地》赞不绝口，我对《黑钱胜地》和身份盗窃赞不绝口。
I've never seen Sean skip over I wanna get to Broadway. I've never seen him go like, we'll get to that. Can we hear about this little show that Sean did at the Tabasco? Oh, the Tabasco. Was he not just spicy as hell in that? Oh.
如果杰森再听我说一次身份盗窃，他会一拳打在我脸上。但它，但——那就是我在高速公路上逆向驾驶的那部电影。那是那部电影吗？是真的吗？对，对，对。
Oscar. It's very, you're very nice to come, Sam. It meant a lot to me. It meant a lot. It was, wait, but seriously, listen, I go on about all you guys and like the rest of the development, I go on about Ozark identity theft.
但我的意思是，我没有，我以前看过你演的一出戏。我没意识到你他妈是个刺客。我知道。我是说，那，一出戏以前我没意识到你他妈是个刺客。我知道，哦，我是说，那他妈的，那是什么？你觉得这也是我们当时被彻底击倒的原因吗，因为我们觉得它不会好。对。
If Jason hears me say identity theft one more time, he's gonna punch me in the face. But it, but- That was the movie I was driving the wrong way down the freeway. Was that the movie? Was it real? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
我们这帮傻瓜。我们当时就坐在那儿。我们打算看一场火车失事。你对我说过。你知道当我们去看首演之夜的时候，杰和我们都在那儿，我们都有点他妈的像，然后杰森，就在大幕落下的时候，杰森转过身看着我，眼里含着泪水，他说，播客
But I mean, I didn't, I'd seen you in a play before. I didn't realize that you're a fucking assassin. I know. I mean, that, a play before I didn't realize that you're a fucking assassin. I know Oh, I mean that what the fuck what was that? And do you think that's why we were also knocked out because we just thought it wasn't gonna be good Yeah We are boy. We just were sitting here. We're gonna watch a train wreck. You said me You know when we went and saw the opening night I jay and we are all we're all there and we were sort of fucking like, and Jason, right as the sort of curtain comes down, Jason turns to me, tears in his eyes, and he goes, podcast
结束了。当它结束时，没有人，戏剧结束了，他在威利和我心中已经赢得了海量的尊重。而那个尊重本来就已经很高了。但看到你做到那一点，你所达到的那个高度，我在哭，在大幕谢幕后大幕落下时，我真的，我转向威尔，我说，好吧，他妈的播客现在毁了。毁了。
is over. When it was over, no one, the play was over and he had just like gained mountains of respect in Will and I's mind and it was already very high. But to see you do that, the level you did it, and I'm crying, and Curtin comes down after the curtain call, and I did, I turned to Will, I said, well the fucking podcast is ruined now. It's ruined.
所以现在你要在痛击痛处上加倍下功夫了。对，当然。我是说，没有什么。这太好了。闭嘴，肖恩。嘿，肖恩，肖恩，肖恩，我能问你一个真正的问题吗？既然我们聊到这个话题，我能认真点吗？你有什么精彩的戏剧故事吗？
So now you're gonna double down on the Busta's chops. Yeah, for sure. I mean, there's nothing. That's very nice. Shut up, Sean. Hey, Sean, Sean, Sean, can I ask you a question for real? Can I be real now that we're on this subject? Do you have any good theater stories?
我们马上回来。热带思慕雪咖啡厅相信你每天都应该享受一次度假，而不仅仅是一年一次。他们正在为他们美味的热带思慕雪、卷饼和薄饼系列推出四款全新热带碗。只要吃上一口他们的新款热带碗，你就会瞬间觉得自己正在度假村放松身心。新款热带碗全部按需现做，顶部铺有清爽的水果、格兰诺拉麦片、奇亚籽和美味的蜂蜜淋酱。蜂蜜？淋酱。
And we will be right back. Tropical Smoothie Cafe believes you deserve a getaway every day, not just once a year. They're introducing four new tropic bowls to their lineup of delicious tropical smoothies, wraps, and flatbreads. One bite of their new tropic bowls and you'll instantly feel like you're relaxing at a resort. The new tropic bowls are all made to order topped with refreshing fruit, granola, chia seeds, and a delicious honey drizzle. Honey? Drizzle.
这才是真正的勺勺五星级奢华体验。我个人点了新款的混合浆果希腊酸奶碗。我喜欢希腊酸奶，我也喜欢用各种水果味的甜食来点缀它。当浆果放进去的时候，我当时想，砰！就像是在我口中完美爆发了所有这些美妙的味道。你知道吗？补充一点蛋白质。
Now that's what I call five-star luxury by the Spoonful. I personally got the new mixed berry Greek yogurt bowl. I like Greek yogurt, and I like dressing it up with a lot of fruity kind of sweet things. And when the berries were in there, I was like, blam! It was like a beautiful explosion in my mouth of all these wonderful tastes. And you know what? Get a little protein.
从来没伤害过任何人。你现在处于“热带时间”了。在当地的热带思慕雪咖啡厅享用新款热带碗，每一勺都是阳光。SmartLess由梅西百货部分赞助播出。情人节就是周三。梅西百货礼品导购让为生命中每一个特别的人（包括你自己）选购礼物变得如此简单。
Never hurt anybody. You're on Tropic Time now. Enjoy Sunshine by the Spoonful with the new Tropic bowls at your local Tropical Smoothie Cafe. SmartLess is brought to you in part by Macy's. Valentine's Day is Wednesday. The Macy's gift finder makes it so easy to shop for everyone special in your life, including you.
这挺有意思的。这个星期天，杰森、威尔和我都要去一个朋友家，因为今天是这个朋友的生日。我们都在为给这个人买什么而苦恼。我们每个人都出了一点钱，给这个人买了一件非常、非常、非常特殊的礼物。我们迫不及待地想把它送给她。所以，如果你还没有为你特别的那个人找到礼物，也不用担心。
It's kind of interesting. This Sunday, Jason, Will, and I are all going to a friend's house because it's this person's birthday. We all struggle to figure out what to get this person. We all chipped in a little bit each of us and got this person something very, very, very special. We can't wait to give it to her. So don't worry if you haven't found a gift yet
梅西百货礼品导购拥有各种价位的惊艳礼品，从奢华大牌到25美元以下应有尽有。无论你是在为生活中的科技达人、体育迷还是大厨挑选礼物，梅西百货都能满足每个人的需求。他们拥有你最喜欢的品牌，比如拉夫·劳伦、蔻驰、耐克等等。他们甚至还有歌帝梵。
for your special someone. Macy's Gift Finder has amazing gifts at any price from luxe to under 25 bucks. Whether you're shopping for the tech guru, sports fan, or chef in your life, Macy's has something for everyone. They have your favorite brands like Ralph Lauren, Coach, Nike, and more. They even have Gadiva.
别忘了给自己也买点小礼物。挑选一处新香水或者一些能让你的美妆保养焕然一新的东西。此外，还可以享受来自CK、盖璞等顶级品牌的内衣和家居服25%到40%的折扣。某些商品可能不适用。我提到的一切以及更多内容都在Macy's.com斜杠Gift Finder。
And don't forget to grab a little something for yourself. Pick up a new fragrance or something to spruce up your beauty regimen. Plus get 25% to 40% off underwear and lingerie from Calvin Klein, Gap, and more top brands. Some exclusions may apply. Everything I mentioned and more is on Macy's.com slash Gift Finder.
那是Macy's.com斜杠gift finder。SmartLess获得Audible的支持。通过最佳体验拉近你与更棒自己的距离。Audible让你在一个应用程序中享受所有音频娱乐。你总能找到你最爱的最佳内容或发现新事物。Audible上有许多健康类别供你选择，例如身体、心理、精神、社交、动机、职业和财务健康。你会找到能够激励你采取行动的声音，或者能够舒缓、帮助你集中注意力、减少
That's Macy's.com slash gift finder. SmartList gets support from Audible. Get closer to the best you. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. There are many wellness categories for you to choose from on Audible such as physical, mental, spiritual, social, motivational, occupational, and financial wellness. You'll find voices that'll motivate you to take action or sounds to soothe, to help you focus, reduce
压力并改善睡眠的声音。作为Audible会员，你每个月可以从整个目录中选择保留一本有声书。顺便说一句，说到减压，我开始听塞巴斯蒂安·马尼斯卡尔科的《保持饥饿》。如果你不认识塞巴斯蒂安，他是我一生中见过最搞笑的人之一。我在流媒体服务上看了他的每一场个人喜剧专场。他太搞笑了。我前几天偶遇了他，我第一次见到了他。
stress, and sleep better. As an audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog. By the way, speaking of reducing stress, I started listening to Stay Hungry by Sebastian Maniscalco. If you don't know Sebastian, he's one of the funniest people I've ever seen in my life. I watched every single special of his on the streaming services. He's so funny. I ran into him the other day and I got to meet him for the first time.
人超级好。我喜欢听他的声音。他太搞笑了，这是一本好书。作为Audible会员，你每个月可以从整个目录中选择保留一本有声书。新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。访问audible.com斜杠smartless或发送短信smartless到500 500。那是audible.com斜杠smartless或发送短信smartless到500 500以免费试用Audible 30天。请务必访问我们的网址，以便他们知道是我们推荐你去的：audible.com斜杠smartless。
Such a super nice guy. I love listening to his voice. He's so funny and it's a great book. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Be sure to visit our URL so they know we sent you audible.com slash smartless.
人真的超级好。我喜欢听他的声音。他太有趣了，而且这是一本很棒的书。作为 Audible 会员，您可以从整个目录中选择每月保留一本图书。新会员可以免费试用 Audible 30 天。请访问 audible.com 斜杠 smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500 500。也就是 audible.com 斜杠 smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500 500 以免费试用 Audible 30 天。请务必访问我们的网址，让他们知道是我们推荐您来的：audible.com 斜杠 smartless。
Be sure to visit our URL so they know we sent you audible.com slash smartlist All right back to the show You know what you know what I'm gonna tell you something and then Sam I want one ready lock the loader so get ready cuz Okay, okay, don't threaten me with a great story But listen, I just sent will this thing that stretches out your calf, because if you stretch out your calves and your hands, you can release your lower back, because Will's been having lower back stuff. So I got that during Good Night Oscar
务必访问我们的网址，让他们知道是我们介绍你来的 audible.com 斜杠 smartlist 好了，回到节目中 你知道吗，你知道吗，我要告诉你一件事，然后山姆，我要准备好一个，锁住装载机，所以准备好，因为 好的，好的，别用一个精彩的故事威胁我 但听着，我刚刚给威尔发了这个东西，可以伸展你的小腿，因为如果你伸展小腿和双手，你就可以放松下背部，因为威尔的下背部一直有问题。所以我是在演《晚安，奥斯卡》时买的
because I started getting plantar fasciitis, like my feet are hurting. Oh yeah. And it was so bad during a couple shows, I was literally shuffling along like I was 95 years old, I was in so much pain doing the show. And two days later, Will, I used that thing I sent you. It was gone.
因为我开始得足底筋膜炎了，我的脚好痛。哦，是的。在好几场演出中痛得太厉害了，我简直像个95岁的老人一样拖着步子走，演演出的时候我痛苦不堪。两天后，威尔，我用了我发给你的那个东西。它就消失了。
Sean, so Sean said- Did you ever get the boot? Yeah, I got the boot. No, it's that thing that kind of rocks, to stretch your calves, right? You put your foot on it and it just- Yeah, and you were sleeping it, right? You're sleeping it's like-
肖恩，所以肖恩说——你买过那个靴子吗？对，我买了那个靴子。不，就是那种会摇晃的、用来拉伸小腿的东西，对吧？你把脚放上去然后就——对，你还穿着它睡觉对吧？你睡觉时就像——
No, no, no, you just stand on it. No, you just stand on it and you just kind of seesaw. My son, Abel, I mean, my son, Danny, who's almost, he's like three and a half, looks like that. Okay, that's something else. Oh, that's advanced. So these guys, I've been having this issue with my, it was my hamstring and then it became like a sort of
不，不，不，你只要站在上面就行。不，你只要站在上面然后像跷跷板一样晃。我的儿子亚伯，我是说，我的儿子丹尼，快要，他大概三岁半了，看起来就是那样。好吧，那是另外一回事了。哦，那是高级货。所以这些家伙，我一直在为我的问题烦恼，先是我的腿筋，然后变成了一种类似
sciatic nerve thing and I'm fucking going to see this guy. We're not going to mention Tariq again. This would be four in a row. We're going to mention Dr. Tariq. Tariq is great. What about Tarik? You know Tarik? Have you seen Doran, the Israeli magician?
坐骨神经的问题，我他妈的去看了这个人。我们不再提塔里克了。这已经是连续第四个了。我们要提塔里克医生。塔里克很棒。塔里克怎么样？你认识塔里克吗？你见过以色列魔术师多兰吗？
No, but do you know Tarik? Wait, you get to watch magic tricks? Okay, so Tarik's the fucker. So I've been going to Tarik. I've been living in his office for the last two years. Tarik is a fan. He's got a great elbow. Doran is also great.
不，但你认识塔里克吗？等等，你可以看魔术表演？好吧，所以塔里克就是那个混蛋。所以我一直去找塔里克。过去两年我基本上住在他的办公室里。塔里克是个粉丝。他手肘很棒。多兰也很棒。
Great, I don't know Doran. I don't know Tarik. Tarik has an unbelievable elbow. When he gets it there, forget it. So anyway, so Sean and Sunday night, we're at dinner with our friends, and he goes, I'm gonna get you this thing, this rocking thing.
太棒了，我不认识多兰。我不认识塔里克。塔里克的肘部功夫令人难以置信。当他按到那个位置时，算了吧。所以不管怎样，肖恩和星期天晚上，我们和朋友一起吃晚饭，他说，我要给你买这个东西，这个会摇晃的东西。
It comes the next day, Monday. I do it yesterday. By yesterday afternoon, I feel infinitely better. Really? That's really good. Oh, really good. It's unreal. You've got to stretch your hands and your calves and you're good to go. Yeah, you must screw it up for a few weeks on that I have I indeed I have it starts with the feet. Yeah
它第二天就到了，星期一。我昨天用了。到昨天下午，我感觉好多了。真的吗？那真的很好。哦，真的很好。太不可思议了。你得拉伸双手和小腿，然后你就可以出发了。对，你一定在这上面搞砸了好几星期，我确实，我确实有，这一切都从脚开始。对
So, so so hand injuries from the car any injuries from Broadway Yeah hamstring. Well, I have had tendinosis two calves from other stuff. That's about it shoulders are creaky Yeah, you know, how old do you know Sam? Two calfs from other stuff. That's about it. Shoulders are creaky. Yeah. How old are you now, Sam? I'm seven to seven. No, I'm 55. Right, so we're all about the same age. You look great.
所以，车子带来的手部受伤，百老汇带来的任何伤情？是的，腿筋。嗯，由于其他原因我得过两次小腿肌腱病。差不多就这些，肩膀有点嘎吱作响 Yeah，你知道，萨姆，你多大了？由于其他原因两个小腿。差不多就这些。肩膀有点嘎吱作响。是啊。你现在多大了，萨姆？我七十七。不，我五十岁。对，所以我们年纪都差不多。你看起来气色真好。
You look plastic. Thanks. You guys look great. Things start to ache a little bit, right? Like, I don't feel like I deserve the kind of knee kind of tweaking or the hip kind of, because we're all staying pretty good shape. We exercise and stuff.
你看起来像整容过的一样。谢谢。你们看起来气色真好。身体开始有点酸痛了，对吧？就像，我觉得我不应该经历那种膝盖被扭到或者臀部出问题的情况，因为我们都保持着相当不错的身材。我们有锻炼什么的。
But you know, the car, the car does break down. It does break down. It's really annoying. But so Sam, go talk to me about the quote, well-paying 1994 Miller Light commercial. Oh my God. Right. So that's when, is that when you knew, like, okay, I got this big commercial.
但你知道，这辆车，这辆车确实会抛锚。它确实会抛锚。真的很烦人。不过，萨姆，跟我聊聊那个所谓的，薪酬丰厚的1994年米勒淡啤酒广告吧。哦，天哪。对。所以那是你意识到，哦，我接到了这个大广告的时候吗？
It pays really well. Maybe I can quit all my other jobs. And what were those other jobs? Well, I worked in a lot of restaurants, Barback, Busboy, I delivered burritos. Wow. I heard your ruffle on what he was bartending. It was kind of a similar time around when I was 28, 29,
报酬真的很丰厚。也许我可以辞掉我所有的其他工作。而那些其他工作是什么？嗯，我在很多餐馆工作过，酒吧助理，收台员，我送过卷饼。哇。我听说你在他当酒保时也差不多。那是大约我28、29岁的时候，
I started working more as an actor. Did started doing movies and stuff, yeah. But delivering burritos on a bicycle was my last job. No shit. Who do you go furthest back with of the actor buddies that you still have? Like, do you go back furthest with like Crude Up or Mark? Well, yeah, Crude Up and Thoreau and I
我开始更多地以演员身份工作。开始拍电影什么的，对。但骑自行车送卷饼是我的最后一份工作。真假的。你和你仍然保持联系的演员死党中，谁的交情最久？比如说，你和克鲁德普或马克谁认识得最久？嗯，对，克鲁德普、梭罗和我
were together during 9-11 and we knew Phil and very happy for Jeffrey Wright and Paul Giammani and Russell. For Tracy, that's Philip Seymour Hoffman. Philip Seymour Hoffman, yes, listen. We don't really mention, as you probably know, we don't really like to mention Thoreau on this podcast. Yes, so we'll cut that out.
在911事件期间我们在一起，我们认识菲尔，并且为杰弗里·怀特、保罗·吉亚玛提和罗素感到非常高兴。致特雷西，那是菲利普·塞默·霍夫曼。菲利普·塞默·霍夫曼，是的，听着。正如你可能知道的那样，我们真的不怎么提，我们在这个播客里其实不太喜欢提梭罗。是的，所以我们会把它剪掉。
We'll go back, we'll trim that out. He's kind of persona non-G around here, you know? Yeah, well. Oh, he's, he have a message for us. He told me to give you a message. He said, you can ask Arnett this question from a listener in New York named Justin T. Will, when you buy button down shirts,
我们会倒回去，把那部分修剪掉。他在这里算是不受欢迎的人，你知道吗？是的，好吧。哦，他，他有话要带给我们。他让我给你带个话。他说，你可以问阿内特一个来自纽约名叫贾斯汀·T的听众的问题：威尔，当你买系扣衬衫时，
do you take them somewhere, take them to someone to remove the top five buttons? Or do you just buy them pre-removed? Also wondering what's your nighttime, let me get this right, decaluge routine. Love the show, keep up the good work. Oh my God, that is so true. Well that's rich coming from a guy that removes the sleeves.
你会把它们拿到什么地方去，找人把上面五个扣子拆掉吗？还是你直接买来时就已经没有那些扣子的？还想知道你的夜间——让我理清一下——日常护肤流程是怎样的。喜欢这个节目，请继续保持。哦，天哪，太真实了。哼，一个自己把袖子剪掉的家伙说这话还真奢侈。
I didn't realize you don't usually button, you don't have any buttons. Is that true? Yeah, it's true. What do you call it? Is that called a burglary? You mean like you go like that? Yeah.
我没意识到你通常不系扣子，你没有任何扣子。是真的吗？是的，是真的。你管这叫什么？这叫入室盗窃吗？你是说你这样吗？对。
I do. I do. If I'm wearing a bun shirt, yeah. I do a lot of this. Why? You know what it is? Because you gotta get people what they want. You gotta get people what they want.
我是。我是。如果我穿着系扣衬衫，是的。我经常这样做。为什么？你知道这是为什么吗？因为你得给人们他们想要的东西。你得给人们他们想要的东西。
This is a world, you have to understand that we are always transmitting and receiving. And so I'm putting out and I'm also receiving. And so I feel from the world they want, they want to get more skin. Sammy knows what I'm talking about. Oh my God. Yeah, you gotta do it.
这是一个世界，你必须明白我们总是在发射和接收。所以我既在输出，也在接收。所以我觉得世界想要的是，他们想要看到更多的皮肤。萨姆知道我在说什么。哦，天哪。是的，你得这么做。
All right, Sammy. Bond dogs. Yes, talk about skin. Yeah, lots of skin on that. I know, right? Wait, so you received critical acclaim and your performance was like incredible. Thank you, thanks.
好了，萨姆。邦多斯。是的，聊聊皮肤。是的，那上面有好多皮肤。我知道，对吧？等等，所以你获得了评论界的好评，你的表演简直不可思议。谢谢，谢谢。
Yeah, I love that moment. Those were the days I had abs. I've not heard of Laundos. Laundos, oh, you gotta see it, it's so good. Yeah, I get naked and I was in good shape back then. That was fun. Is that the thing you think kind of opened the doors for you, the porn?
是的，我喜欢那个时刻。那是我有腹肌的日子。我没听说过《邦多斯》。《邦多斯》，哦，你得看看，太棒了。是的，我脱光了衣服，那时我身材很好。那很有趣。你觉得那是为你打开大门的契机吗，那部色情片？
Yeah, I think so. I think that was one of them. Did Safe Men with Paul Giamani, Ruffalo, Dinklage? I was going to say Safe Men that Hamburg, right? Wasn't that Hamburg? You know Safe Men? Yeah, it's a little, it's a little gem, I think. I knew those guys, I knew some of those guys, those guys who produced it, I think they were
是的，我想是的。我想那是其中之一。和保罗·吉亚玛提、鲁法洛、丁拉基合作过《安全之交》？我本来想说汉堡拍的《安全之交》，对吧？那不是汉堡吗？你知道《安全之交》吗？是的，那是一部，我认为是一部小珍宝。我认识那些家伙，我认识其中一些家伙，制作这部电影的家伙，我想他们就是
the same dudes who made my buddy Steps movie that I did. Anyway, great guys. Yeah, and then Box of Moonlight was, those guys. And then Box of Moonlight was those three kinda. Box of Moonlight. Yeah. Help me get, and then Galaxy Quest and bring Miles for a half. Okay, so I wanna talk about Galaxy Quest.
拍了我朋友斯泰普斯的电影的同一群人。不管怎样，都是好人。是的，然后《月光宝盒》是，那些家伙。然后《月光宝盒》是那三个某种程度上。月光宝盒。是的。帮我弄到，然后是《银河系漫游生死恋》和带迈尔斯走一半。好吧，所以我想谈谈《银河系漫游生死恋》。
It's one of my favorite movies. Dude, I saw Safeman. I really love Safeman by the way, and I knew a lot of those dudes. But then when you did fucking Galaxy Quest, Rockwell, you absolutely destroyed. Yeah, incredible. You destroyed it, right?
这是我最喜欢的电影之一。老兄，我看过《安全之交》。顺便说一句，我真的很喜欢《安全之交》，而且我认识很多那些家伙。但是当你拍了该死的《银河系漫游生死恋》时，洛克威尔，你简直演得炸裂了。是的，难以置信。你演得太棒了，对吧？
Incredible, thanks guys. Dude, I auditioned for the Enrico, Colin Jones part. Oh yeah. Yeah, still waiting here. You're not right for it. I know I'm not right for it. Well, they agreed, but I'm just saying that. You're not right.
太棒了，谢谢你们，伙计们。老兄，我曾为恩里科·科隆·琼斯的角色试镜。哦，是吗？是的，还在等消息呢。你不适合这个角色。我知道我不适合。好吧，他们也同意，但我只是这么说。你确实不适合。
So wait, this is from, so your character Guy Fleegman, right? Yes. He was so, he was so fun and great. Fuck. It was like a pick me energy. This is from Scotty, okay? No boy.
所以等等，这是来自，所以你的角色盖伊·弗里格曼，对吧？是的。他太，他太有趣太棒了。操。这有一种“选我”的能量。这是来自斯科蒂的，好吗？不，孩子。
Scotty said the whole bit about you not wanting to be sent down first, your character, like whenever you go to a planet, those characters always died. That was a reference to Star Trek, you probably know this, Star Trek and the red shirts. Yes.
斯科蒂说，关于你不想第一个被传送下去的整段戏，你的角色，就像每当你去一个星球，那些角色总是会死。这是一个对《星际迷航》的致敬，你可能知道这个，《星际迷航》和红衫队员。是的。
Which are expendables. But a lot of people don't know that. I didn't know that. That in Star Trek, whenever Spock and Kirk would come to a planet. That's right. They would always send these guys down first and they would always die.
也就是炮灰。但很多人并不知道这一点。我不知道这一点。在《星际迷航》中，每当斯波克和柯克来到一个星球。没错。他们总是先派这些家伙下去，然后他们总是会死。
It was such a funny time. I just kind of stole my performance from Bill Paxton and Aliens pretty much. Hey, Sean, just widen out. I just want to see if I can see the make out, the mountain dew on your desk, if it's possible. If I get the fucking monster energy trick. And the Star Trek cosplay outfit.
那真是一段搞笑的时光。我的表演基本上就是从《异形》里的比尔·帕克斯顿那里偷来的。嘿，肖恩，画面拉远一点。我只是想看看能不能看到你桌子上的山露，如果可能的话。如果我能玩到那个该死的疯狂怪物能量饮料的把戏。还有《星际迷航》的cosplay服装。
I mean, yeah. No, but it was, you know what though? It is true. That was the first time somebody sort of made that kind of joke on screen. Your fucking delivery, Sammy. It's just fucking unreal. Every time.
我是说，是的。不，但是，你知道吗？这是真的。那是第一次有人在银幕上开这种玩笑。你他妈的台词功底，萨姆。简直他妈的太不可思议了。每次都是。
We lucked out with that movie. Sam, you're one of those guys, and I talk about this from time to time on the podcast You're one of those people. It doesn't matter what you're doing. It never it could be the worst You never suck you could be in the worst movie the worst play the worst TV you're always Committed I fucking love that about I know I love that too. Do you ever feel like I was gonna say the same thing Do you ever feel like movie to movie? Obviously? same thing. Do you ever feel like movie to movie? Obviously you never know what you got
我们拍那部电影真是走运。萨姆，你是那种人，我有时会在播客中谈到这一点，你就是那种人。不管你在做什么，永远不会。哪怕是最糟的你也从不拉胯。你可能身处最烂的电影、最烂的戏剧、最烂的电视剧中，但你总是全情投入。我他妈太喜欢这一点了，我知道我也很喜欢这一点。你有没有觉得，我刚想说同样的话。你有没有觉得，从一部电影到另一部电影？显然，永远不知道你拍的是什么
or what you're in or what you have. Can you feel it by now at this point in your career as you're going day one, day week one, month one, month two. You know what, I think I'm in a piece of shit or I think this is working. Or I think this is really working. Cause I said when I did Good Night Oscar, we had an invited dress rehearsal
或者你身处什么戏中，或者你手里有什么。到了你职业生涯的这个阶段，当你经历第一天、第一周、第一个月、第二个月时，你能感觉得到吗？你知道吗，我想我正身处一坨狗屎中，或者我觉得这行得通。或者我觉得这真的行得通。因为我说过，当我演《晚安，奥斯卡》时，我们有一场彩排
with a bunch of kids who didn't get any of the references because it takes place in the 50s. And it was crickets the whole play. I came home to Scotty, I said I'm in a piece of shit. Yeah, it's always scary, isn't it? Yeah, it's scary. And the next night it was. Yeah, that's a great thing. So what is Yeah, it's scary. Yeah, the next night was yeah
台下坐着一群根本听不懂任何梗的孩子，因为故事发生在50年代。整场话剧下来鸦雀无声。我回到斯科蒂家，我说我正在演一坨狗屎。是的，总是很吓人，对吧？是的，很吓人。而第二天晚上情况就。是的，这太棒了。所以什么是 是的，很吓人。是的，第二天晚上情况就，是的
Yeah, you that's a great thing. So what is your brum around that? Like how do you feel? Well, first of all, thank you and right back at you all three of you guys and but but yeah, I I think you always think It's fucking Hamlet, right? I mean you think it's Citizen Kane I mean when you're working on and then at a certain point You realize maybe it's not. And then- Yeah, starts to take on water. Yeah, yeah. And then you're like, oh yeah.
是的，这太棒了。那么你对此的反应是什么？比如你感觉如何？首先，谢谢你，同样的话也送给你们三位，但是，但是，是的，我想你总是认为这是他妈的《哈姆雷特》，对吧？我的意思是，你会以为这是《公民凯恩》，当你正在创作时，然后在某个时刻，你会意识到也许并不是。然后——是的，开始进水了。是的，是的。然后你会想，哦，是的。
And then you're like, oh shit, this could be bad. This could be, I remember Baldwin once saying to me, Alec once says to me, he goes, he goes, he never, he goes like, you never intend to make a bad movie. He goes, you know, you go like, you agree to do with something and you're making this movie with people
然后你会想，哦操，这可能会很糟。这可能会，我记得鲍德温曾经对我说过，亚历克曾对我说过，他说，他从不，他说，你绝不是故意去拍一部烂电影的。他说，你知道，你会想，你同意做某件事，你和人们一起拍这部电影
and they go, hey, we're gonna go over here. And you go, great, I can't wait. I'm excited to go over here. And then you start making it. And all of a sudden you start going to the other direction. You go, hey, I thought we were going over there. And they're like, no, no, no, no, no,
他们说，嘿，我们要去这边。然后你说，太棒了，我等不及了。我很兴奋能去那边。然后你开始拍了。突然之间，你们开始朝另一个方向走。你就会说，嘿，我以为我们要去那边的。他们却说，不，不，不，不，不，
we're going over here. Yeah, yeah. And you can, yeah. Sometimes it comes from watching another performance or a decision a director makes or just the general vibe on the set from the crew or whatever, and you could start to smell it, right? And you just can't get, there's nothing you can do about it because you're only doing one little piece of it.
我们要去那边。是的，是的。而且你可以，有时这来自于观看另一场表演，或导演做出的决定，或来自剧组或其他人员的片场总体氛围，你开始闻到不对劲的味道了，对吧？而你却无能为力，因为你只是在做其中的一小部分。
That's, it's just a team. Does it take away the energy and like, do you start depleting yourself of kind of the same chutzpah you and came in? I don't think you do. You always deliver the... Well, I think if you sign up and you get talked, I think when you get talked into something,
这，这只是一个团队。这会消磨精力和热情吗？你会不会开始耗尽你刚来时的那种冲劲？我觉得不会。你总是能呈现出……嗯，我觉得如果你签约了，而且你是被说服的，我觉得当你被说服去做某事时，
and I won't mention any names, but when you get talked into something, that's when it's bad, you know what I mean? And you try to do a fixer-upper thing on it. Right, but you have, you know, Willie, you said that he fully commits, and that's certainly part of why he's so great, but I've seen a lot of crappy actors
我不会提及任何名字，但当你被说服去做某事时，那才是糟糕的时候，你知道我的意思吗？而你却试图在上面做一个修补匠的工作。没错，但是你知道，威尔，你说过他会全身心投入，这当然是他如此优秀的一部分原因，但我见过很多糟糕的演员
fully commit to a crappy performance that doesn't fix it. I mean, he's fully committing to a performance that's coming from a guy with great taste. There's somehow that you have the ability to keep one eye on yourself and judge whether the choice you're making sucks or not. And you're staying away from sucky choices with the way in which you play characters.
把一个糟糕的表演演得全身心投入，但这并没有拯救那个表演。我的意思是，他是全身心地投入到一个由品位极佳的人带来的表演中。某种程度上，你拥有这种能力，能一边演一边用一只眼睛审视自己，判断你所做出的选择到底是烂还是不烂。而且你通过塑造角色的方式，避开了那些烂透了的选择。
Is that- Sean, Sean, do you make a lot of sucky choices in your life? Do you make a lot of sucky choices? your life? Do you make a lot of sucky choices? Ignore that, Sam. Ignore it. You know, you wanna make God laugh telling your plans, right? So I just never know.
是这样吗——肖恩，肖恩，你在生活中做过很多烂选择吗？你在生活中做过很多烂选择吗？你的生活？你做过很多烂选择吗？忽略那个，萨姆。忽略它。你知道的，你想让上帝发笑就说出你的计划，对吧？所以我永远不知道。
You never know. Right, but you have good taste. Did that come from, did you get it from mom or dad or from watching a bunch of great stuff? You know, again, I think it's just more ego to be frank. I think it's more like just wanting to have a big part of it. Have a reason to get up there. Right, and doing something
你永远不知道。没错，但你很有品位。这是从哪来的？你是从妈妈或爸爸那里学来的，还是通过看很多伟大的作品学来的？你知道，再次声明，坦白说，我觉得这更多是出于虚荣心。我觉得这更像是想要在其中占据重要部分。有一个上台的理由。没错，做一些
that you're gonna wanna watch. It doesn't mean that it has to be a lead role. It can be a supporting role. Sure. Yeah, that you're gonna wanna be a part of, so. Do you watch your stuff? Are you one of those actors that can't watch? If it's good, if it's good, it can be a supporting role. Yeah, that you're gonna wanna be a part of, so. Do you watch your stuff? Do you, are you one of those actors that can't watch? If it's good, if it's good, it's like a home movie.
你自己也想看的东西。这并不意味着它必须是一个主角。它可以是一个配角。当然。是的，你想成为其中的一部分，所以。你看你自己的作品吗？你是那种无法观看自己作品的演员吗？如果它是好的，如果是好的，它可以是一个配角。是的，你想成为其中的一部分，所以。你看你自己的作品吗？你，你是那种无法观看自己作品的演员吗？如果它是好的，如果是好的，它就像家庭录像一样。
If it comes on, Seven Psychopaths came on. I love, that experience was really great. Yeah, I hear Martin McDonough is just about the best guy in the world to work with. He's the best man, you know, and Chris Walk and I done a play with him and then we did the movie and Colin and Woody, so we had, you know and Chris walk and I done a play with him and then we did the movie and Colin and Woody So yeah, you know, it was just a really nice time. We had a great time
如果它播出来，七个神经病播出来。我喜欢，那段经历真的很棒。是的，我听说马丁·麦克多纳几乎是世界上最好合作的人了。他是最棒的，你知道，克里斯·沃肯和我跟他合作过一出戏，然后我们拍了这部电影，还有科林和伍迪，所以我们，你知道的，克里斯·沃肯和我跟他合作过一出戏，然后我们拍了这部电影，还有科林和伍迪 所以，你知道的，那真是一段美好的时光。我们度过了一段美好的时光
Yeah, so it's like a isn't it's like a home movie right when you see and it's either a bad experience or a good experience You know, but but what about like on set? Will you watch playback to sort of to help in calibrating your performance? Or do you like stay in the dark only if it's like in calibrating your performance or do you like to stay in the dark? Only if it's mainly for the canvas or if I'm a lot of times just to get maybe a tone and then I stay away from it. And a lot of times I'm noticing if I do look at it, I'm under where I used to be over the top. But I'm noticing it's actually I need more and then I need to contain it.
是的，所以这就像一个，这不就像家庭录像吗，当你看到它时，要么是一段糟糕的经历，要么是一段美好的经历，你知道，但是，但是在片场呢？你会看回放来帮助调整你的表演吗？或者你喜欢保持黑暗，只在如果是的话，来调整你的表演，或者你喜欢保持黑暗？只有在主要是为了看画布或者如果我很多时候只是为了抓住一个基调，然后我就离它远远的。而且很多时候我注意到，如果我确实看了，我往往会演得过头，而我以前总是用力过猛。但我注意到其实我需要更多，然后我需要收敛一点。
I would say tell the director to bring the camera closer instead of you reaching out. It's actually, I need more and then I need to contain it. I would say tell the director to bring the camera closer instead of you reaching out, you know? Fuckin', if they can't see it, they gotta get closer. You stay small. Or bring your own. Yeah, if you bring your own. We're one of those go pros turned back on yourself.
我会说让导演把镜头拉近，而不是你去够镜头。实际上，我需要更多，然后我需要收敛。我会说让导演把镜头拉近，而不是你去够镜头，你知道吗？操，如果他们看不见，他们就得靠近点。你保持微小。或者带你自己的。是的，如果你带你自己的。我们就像那种对着自己的GoPro。
When you say to see the canvas, do you, and to see the canvas and the tone are those two different things? Like, do you mean sometimes that you actually look and go like, because when you're in it, you don't have a sense of like the bigger picture. And then when you get to see it, you go, oh, okay, okay. Whether in terms of staging and what effect is.
当你说“看画布”时，你看画布和基调是两码事吗？我的意思是，有时你真的看一眼然后觉得，因为当你身处其中时，你对更大的画面没有概念。然后当你看到它时，你会想，哦，好吧，好吧。无论是在舞台调度还是效果方面。
I guess I'm talking about stakes, you know. I'm talking about stakes. Interesting. You know, Crude Up is one of the people I've gone to, beyond my acting coach or my friend, Chris Messina, who you know, I'll go to, I've gone to a lot of friends for help. Stanley Tucci, lots of people. And but Crude Up is particularly bad. So he's rough, man.
我想我指的是 stakes（赌注/重要性），你知道的。我指的是 stakes。有趣。你知道，克鲁德普是我求助的人之一，除了我的表演教练或我的朋友克里斯·墨西拿（你认识的），我会去找很多朋友帮忙。斯坦利·图齐，还有很多人。但克鲁德普特别刻薄。所以他很严厉，老兄。
Sorry, I cut you off. Yeah. Yeah, he's gotta go back to NYU. Yeah. He's so fragile. And he's hard to look at. Hard to look at. He's tough to look at.
抱歉，我打断你了。是的。是的，他得回纽约大学去。是的。他太脆弱了。而且看着让人难受。看着难受。看着他太难受了。
He's tough to look at. No, you're gonna say he's particularly helpful? Yeah, he's very articulate about acting. He can, I went to him with American Buffalo. I was like, I was losing my saliva. Literally, I couldn't get through the speech. And I went, he can, I went to American Buffalo, I was like, I was losing my saliva, literally, I couldn't get through the speech. And I went, I said, man, I need your help, man. I gotta, I gotta, I can't get through this fucking thing.
看着他太难受了。不，你是想说他特别有帮助吗？是的，他对表演非常有见地。他能，我带着《美国水牛城》去找他。我当时，我感觉我的口水都要说干了。真的，我连台词都念不下去。我去找了，他能，我带着《美国水牛城》去找他。我当时，我感觉我的口水都要说干了。真的，我连台词都念不下去。我去找了，我说，老兄，我需要你的帮助，老兄。我得，我得，我实在念不完这该死的东西。
And he came over and he really, he really helped me. He really broke it down for me. He's really smart. Yeah, what was it, sir? Yeah. What's the key to keeping your mouth nice and lubricated? Who's this for? Who's that question for?
然后他过来了，他真的，他真的帮了我。他真的为我剖析了剧本。他真的很聪明。是的，那是怎么回事，先生？是的。保持口腔湿润的秘诀是什么？这是问谁的？这个提问是针对谁的？
It's a question. Sorry, I was looking at you. Okay, okay. Very quick question. Okay. Voice warmups, Sean, voice warmups, right? Very good, very good. Keeping, I mean they say bite your tongue,
这是一个问题。抱歉，我刚才看着你呢。好吧，好吧。非常快的问题。好吧。嗓音热身，肖恩，嗓音热身，对吧？非常好，非常好。保持，我是说他们说咬舌头，
but you know, I do a voice warmup, 20 minute link later warmup. Yeah. Also, isn't it wild when you're doing a live a lot It's real or yes, that's good when you're doing a live play that you've created this character and this world Yeah through weeks of rehearsals then you get up on a piece. So you created this piece of art and You think people will know your choices like think, so for your speech for example, you're like, well, I can't change it.
但是你知道，我做一个嗓音热身，20分钟的雷克莱尔热身。是的，另外，当你做现场直播时，不是很疯狂吗？很多，这是真的，是的，这很好，当你正在排演一出你创作了这个角色和这个世界的现场话剧时，是的，通过几个星期的排练，然后你上台表演这个片段。所以你创作了这个艺术品，你以为人们会懂你的选择，就像，比如你的台词，你会觉得，嗯，我不能改。
It's, this is how it's supposed to go. But people don't know that. So you're like, well, I don't want to change. But you're like, hey buddy, you could take the biggest pause in the world in the middle of a monologue, drink a glass of water. You can do any, you can add anything. Nobody knows how it's supposed to go.
它是，这应该是这样的。但人们并不知道这一点。所以你会想，好吧，我不想改变。但你会想，嘿，老兄，你可以在独白中间停顿全世界最长的时间，喝杯水。你可以做任何事，你可以添加任何东西。没有人知道它本来应该是什么样子的。
But in your mind, you're like no no I'm compromising The role I'm compromising the part and that's the thing I was bump up against I want I once saw John Malkovich do burn this Oh, yeah, I saw that right so what about that opening opening monologue as he comes in after you know fucking trying to get a parking Spot out in front of the goddamn building and he's fixing his hair in the mirror And he stops in the middle of this in in the middle of a sentence, not in a punctuation, but in the middle of a sentence for at least a minute while he's fucking with his hair and then picks right back up on his monologue another minute or two, you know, talking.
但在你的脑海里，你会想，不，不，我在妥协这个角色，我在妥协这个部分，这就是我一直在抗拒的事情。我曾经看到约翰·马尔科维奇演《Burn This》。哦，是的，我看到了！所以，关于那段开场独白，他在大楼门外试着找停车位，然后进来，在镜子里整理头发，他在独白中间停了下来，不是在标点符号处，而是在句子的中间，停顿了至少有一分钟，同时还在弄他的头发，然后又接着他的独白继续往下说，又过了一两分钟，你知道，在说话。
I just couldn't believe the balls. Yeah. You know, I was a young actor watching this and I was like, oh, fuck, that's incredible what this guy does. Incredible. He's one of my favorites. That performance was unbelievable. Yeah. It was unbelievable. I was a young actor watching this like oh fuck that's incredible what this guy does Favorites that performance was unbelievable. Yeah, yeah unbelievable. So anyway, I added two glasses of water in the scene I'm like, I think my character should drink water now. Yeah, no Absolutely, I just six page money like I had the director. I said can I have like a water fountain? He said no Well, what can I can I have it? I just put, get a lifesaver. I was in a park.
我简直不敢相信他的胆量。是的。你知道，我当时是一个年轻的演员，看着这一幕，我心想，哦，操，这家伙做的事太不可思议了。难以置信。他是我最喜欢的演员之一。那个表演简直不可思议。是的。简直不可思议。我是一个年轻的演员看着这一幕，心想，哦，操，这家伙做的事太不可思议了 最喜欢的演员，那个表演简直不可思议。是的，是的，难以置信。所以不管怎样，我在那场戏里加了两杯水。我说，我觉得我的角色现在应该喝水。是的，绝对的，我只是那段六页纸的独白，我让导演。我说，我能弄个饮水机吗？他说，不行。好吧，那我能，我能弄吗？我只是，拿个救生糖。我当时在一个公园里。
And so I was like, all right. Now I'll ask you a real hacky question here that there is no answer for, but I'll ask anyway, you prefer doing theater over camera work? No, I mean, it's totally different. I think it's just the gym and it's really scary. And it's like going to the gym and it informs your film work, I'd say, but it helps.
所以我就想，好吧。现在我来问你一个非常外行的问题，这个问题没有答案，但我还是要问，你更喜欢演话剧还是拍电影？不，我的意思是，这完全不同。我觉得这就像去健身房，这真的很吓人。这就像去健身房，它对你的电影表演有帮助，我可以说，但它很有帮助。
Like Chris Walken does that monologue in Pulp Fiction. I think it's because he did Hamlet and he did Rose Tattoo. Yes, but Stanley Kowalski. But would you not agree that if you do a stage level performance in front of the camera, you'd be doing too much? Oh yeah, for sure. Definitely. But interesting, for sure. Definitely. But interesting, say you talk about that, talk about that idea, it's like going to the
就像克里斯·沃肯在《低俗小说》里那段独白。我想那是因为他演过《哈姆雷特》和《玫瑰刺青》。是的，还有斯坦利·科瓦尔斯基。但是难道你不认为，如果你在镜头前表现出舞台级别的表演，你就会用力过猛吗？哦，是的，肯定的。绝对的。但有趣的是，肯定的。绝对的。但有趣的是，你谈到这个，谈到那个概念，这就好比去
gym for film work. Well, it's just obviously you can't screen, you can't do a stage performance, especially the ones I've done, because they're big. You know, in front of a camera that would not work,. But I think all you gotta do is turn the volume down, I guess, I mean, maybe that's not as simple as it sounds. But. Was calibrating. Do you enjoy the bigger movement
电影工作的健身房。嗯，很显然，你不能尖叫，你不能做舞台表演，尤其是像我做过的那种，因为它们太宏大了。你知道，在镜头前那样是行不通的。但我认为你所需要做的就是把音量调小，我想，也许这并没有听起来那么简单。但是。关于校准。你喜欢更大的肢体动作，
or do you enjoy getting super, super small, letting the camera find the little stuff? I prefer being small even on stage. I don't wanna get big on stage, in fact. I think that's the trick of, but I've never done a musical. So I don't know, that's a whole other thing. But I think keeping it real and still being loud,
还是喜欢变得超级、超级小，让镜头去捕捉那些细微之处？我更喜欢收敛，即使在舞台上也是如此。事实上，我不想在舞台上表现得太夸张。我认为这就是诀窍，但我从来没演过音乐剧。所以我不懂，那是完全不同的另一回事。但我认为，保持真实的同时声音依然洪亮，
with you're still being able to hit the back row with your voice is a trick, you know? Yeah, right. Phil Hoffman taught me a lot about that. I mean, sounds name-dropping, but he also is somebody who, he directed me in a play and he, he was very, you know, but no, but listener doesn't want to hear about process. Well, should they do, they'll listen to whatever, they have to listen to whatever
声音依然能够穿透最后一排，这就是诀窍，你知道吗？是的，没错。菲尔·霍夫曼教了我很多关于这方面的知识。我的意思是，听起来像是在炫耀人脉，但他也确实是那种人，他曾指导过我的一出戏，他，他非常，你知道的，不过算了，听众才不想听什么创作过程呢。好吧，他们想听就听，他们必须听我们他妈的在聊什么
the fuck we talk about. By the way, the podcast, it's free, and they can not listen. By the way, the podcast, it's free. They can not listen. Yeah, man, what the fuck? What the fuck? I love hearing you talk about this shit. I do feel. Well, Phil was the, he was, you guys know him. He was, yeah, of course.
顺便说一句，这个播客是免费的，他们也可以不听。顺便说一句，这个播客是免费的。他们可以不听。是的，老兄，什么鬼？什么鬼？我喜欢听你们聊这些废话。我确实觉得。嗯，菲尔是那个，他是，你们都认识他。他是，是的，当然。
I'm envious that you guys knew him and I didn't. But dad, tell me about, do you like doing doing I love that whenever you're doing a like a lead role in a film? I just like because I'm just I want more of you at all times But oftentimes the lead role is not as spicy or as fun as As some of the the secondary or tertiary roles. What's your, do you have a preference? Yeah, you know, I think that's something, I mean, here we go with the name drop shit, but Clooney, I think-
我很嫉妒你们认识他而我却不认识。但是老爸，跟我说说，你喜欢做，喜欢做？我喜欢每当你在一部电影里担任主角的时候？我只是喜欢，因为我随时都想要更多的你。但通常情况下，主角并不像某些配角或龙套角色那样辛辣有趣。你有什么，你有什么偏好吗？是的，你知道，我觉得那是，我的意思是，又开始扯那些大人物的名字了，但是克鲁尼，我觉得——
George Clooney. George Clooney. I don't know, Clooney's not a name drop here. Yeah. Yeah. But Clooney taught me a lot of, you know, cause I come in with all these props and all these, I'd be smacking it up and...
乔治·克鲁尼。乔治·克鲁尼。我不知道，克鲁尼在这里可算不上炫耀人脉。是的。是的。但克鲁尼教了我很多，你知道的，因为我带着一堆道具去，带着所有这些东西，我会在每一场戏里都大肆发挥……
Well, you were the lead in his first film, right? And I was the lead in the film and he's like, hey man, you know, we can't do bows with a clown every scene, you know, we gotta... I mean, he didn't say that. That was the note? He didn't say that. But I was like, you know, zero my style in there.
嗯，你是他第一部电影的主角，对吧？而我是那部电影的主角，他就像，嘿，老兄，你知道的，我们不能在每一场戏里都像个小丑一样搞怪，你知道，我们得……我的意思是，他没这么说。那是给你的意见？他没这么说。但我就像，你知道，把我的风格融入其中。
I mean, one of the great actors zero my style. But, you know, he said, you know too many props and let's just keep it You're the you're the lead guy. You got to like keep it simple and I learned a lot from him about that It's it's true because it's a canvas, right? So you're not necessarily the color red all the time, you know Kevin Costner and dances with wolves I mean, he's you know, they gotner and dances with Wolves. I mean, he's, you know, they got other people providing those colors. Yeah, you gotta really,
我的意思是，伟大的演员之一，把我的风格融入其中。但是，你知道，他说，你用了太多道具，咱们还是保持简单吧。你是主角。你得保持简单，我从他身上学到了很多关于这方面的知识。这确实是真的，因为这是一张画布，对吧？所以你不一定非要一直都是红色，你知道的。凯文·科斯特纳在《与狼共舞》中，我的意思是，他是，你知道的，他们有其他人来提供那些颜色。是的，你真的必须，
you really suss that out when you read the script and you talk about it and you develop it and you show up, you're like, where do I fit? Yeah. Yeah. And you have to be, sometimes you have to be a blank canvas, right? If you're the lead in a certain way,
当你读剧本、讨论剧本、构思剧本并出现在片场时，你必须把这些摸透，你会想：我该如何融入其中？是的。是的。而且你必须，有时你必须是一张空白的画布，对吧？如果你在某种程度上是主角，
you have to be able to let other colors. Jason, obviously has been a blank canvas to me for so many years. He's been this off-white mayonnaise, sort of egg shell color. Well, I think Jason's performance in identity theft is, is, is so good. Now you love identity theft.
你必须能够让其他颜色进来。多年来，杰森显然一直是我的空白画布。他一直是那种米白色、蛋壳色。嗯，我觉得杰森在《身份贼中贼》里的表演，简直太棒了。现在你很喜欢《身份贼中贼》。
It's really fucking amazing. Let's walk through identity theft. Let's show a clip. We'll just show a real quick clip. Let's go to clip. That is pretty amazing. By the way, I will say, I will say, I love identity theft as well. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that.
真的他妈的太惊艳了。让我们来回顾一下《身份贼中贼》。让我们放个片段。我们就放一个非常短的片段。让我们转到片段。那真是太惊艳了。顺便说一句，我要说的是，我要说的是，我也很喜欢《身份贼中贼》。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。
I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that.
我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。
I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what's that. I don't even know what you not seen Game Night? I need to see that. It's so fucking... It's so fucking...
我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。难道你没看过《游戏之夜》吗？我得去看看。那部片子太他妈的……太他妈的……
It's so funny. I can't even watch that. Jason is so good at that. Jason is... It's... And he knows how to play stakes, right? Dude. And still be like, you know...
太搞笑了。我甚至都看不了那个。杰森在那里面太棒了。杰森是……这……而且他懂得如何掌控局势，对吧？老兄。而且依然能像，你知道的……
Dude. It is a... That movie holds up to multiple viewings. Yeah, that's one of my favorites. It's fucking... By the way, Game Night is one of the most... It's one of the like, last great... I haven't seen a By the way, Game Night is one of the most, is one of the like last great, I haven't seen a great film comedy since Game Night.
老兄。这是一部……那部电影经得起多次反复观看。是的，那是我的最爱之一。这他妈的……顺便说一句，《游戏之夜》是最……它是近年来最后几部伟大的喜剧之一，自从《游戏之夜》之后我还没看过一部……
Game Night, it's, yeah. I'm not, I'm kidding. Those guys, it's John and John. It's gonna be your new identity, thief. John with that. It's not, yeah. Sam, you have not seen it yet, right? I haven't seen it, no.
《游戏之夜》，它是，是的。我不是，我开玩笑呢。那些家伙，那是约翰和约翰。它将成为你的新《身份贼中贼》。约翰带着那个。它不是，是的。萨姆，你还没看过，对吧？我没看过，没有。
So good. Oh, it's Rachel McAdams. I've seen Marvel bosses, I've seen, I've seen the one. Jesse Plem good. Oh, it's rich. I'm a guy that's more of a boss. I've seen I've seen the one Jesse Plemons. You piss in the pond and oh, yeah, the magic pond with Ryan. Yeah. That's you know, it was really funny in that movie Billy Magnussen. Yeah. He'd that guy's a real talent.
太棒了。哦，那是瑞秋·麦克亚当斯。我看过漫威反派，我看过，我看过那部。杰西·普莱蒙演得很好。哦，太棒了。我是一个更喜欢反派的人。我看过，我看过有杰西·普莱蒙的那部。你在池塘里撒尿，哦，是的，和瑞安一起的那个神奇池塘。是的。你知道的，比利·马格努森在那部电影里真的很好笑。是的。这家伙真是个天才。
He is hilarious. Yeah. He is a good and Sharon Horgans in it too. Sharon Horgans is amazing. Kyle Sharon Horgan's in it too. Sharon Horgan is amazing. Kyle Chandler from Friday Night Lights. How great is Kyle? We have fucking Sam's with us. Sam Rockwell. Let's talk about all his things.
他太滑稽了。是的。他很棒，沙朗·霍根也在里面。沙朗·霍根太棒了。凯尔，沙朗·霍根也在里面呢。沙朗·霍根太棒了。来自《胜利之光》的凯尔·钱德勒。凯尔有多棒？我们有他妈的萨姆和我们在一起。萨姆·洛克威尔。让我们聊聊他的所有作品。
Game night, I'm on it. We'll be right back. Our thanks to Liquid IV for supporting SmartLess. So when it's time to start another big week, celebrate Hydration Monday with Liquid IV, which three times the electrolytes of the leading sports drink plus eight vitamins and nutrients, Liquid IV is there to kick off your week right.
《游戏之夜》，我这就去看。我们马上回来。感谢Liquid IV对SmartLess的大力支持。所以当又一个重大的一周开始时，用Liquid IV来庆祝水分补充星期一吧，它含有普通运动饮料三倍的电解质以及八种维生素和营养成分，Liquid IV能让你的新的一周有一个正确的开始。
All you need is one stick of Liquid IV and 16 ounces of water to boost your hydration. You know what guys, it's really easy to forget about your hydration when you wake up in the morning, you're running around and you're going from this place to that place, driving here, doing that, maybe you're forgetting to eat even. With as busy as your schedule is, you have to remember to hydrate. Liquid IV makes it so easy.
你只需要一支Liquid IV和16盎司的水就能提升你的水分吸收。你知道吗，伙计们，早上醒来时真的很容易忘记补充水分，你到处奔波，从这个地方赶到那个地方，开车去这儿，做那个，甚至可能忘了吃饭。伴随着如此繁忙的日程，你必须记得补充水分。Liquid IV让这一切变得如此简单。
For me, sometimes I'll take a stick of liquid IV, put it in the 16 ounces of water, and put that bottle of water next to my bed. In the morning, it's the first thing I do, so I stay hydrated all day long. My schedule's pretty busy on the weekends weekends especially because I push all my social events a lot to the weekends and so I'm running around extra crazy on the weekends and that's when I forget to hydrate. Weekends are for going wild. Have a game plan for Monday with Liquid IV.
对我来说，有时我会拿一支Liquid IV，把它放进16盎司的水里，然后把那瓶水放在我的床头。早晨醒来，这是我做的第一件事，所以我整天都能保持水分充足。我的日程安排在周末相当满，特别是周末，因为我把大部分社交活动都推到了周末，所以我在周末会格外疯狂地奔跑，而那就是我忘记补水的时候。周末就是用来尽情狂欢的。用Liquid IV为星期一制定一个游戏计划吧。
Grab your Liquid IV hydration multiplier sugar-free in bulk nationwide at Costco or get 20% off your first order when you go to liquidiv.com and use code smartLIS at checkout. That's 20% off your first order when you shop superior hydration today using promo code smartLIS at liquidiv.com. ["Sugar-Free"]
全国范围内的Costco均可批量购买无糖型Liquid IV补水倍增器，或者访问liquidiv.com并在结账时使用代码smartLIS，首单即可享受20%的折扣。今天访问liquidiv.com购物，使用促销代码smartLIS，首单即可立享卓越补水体验八折优惠。["无糖"]
Thanks to our sponsor, CarShield, for their support. The hard truth is the price of many car parts has increased by almost 100%. That means when you need a car repair, you could be paying double plus the cost of labor. With CarShield, customers don't have to worry about the cost of covered car parts. Their plans can cover up to 5,000 parts and systems. You can get coverage on things like your engine, transmission, brakes, AC, electrical system, and much more. In some cases, a deductible may apply. With protection plans starting at around $100 a month, CarShield offers varying levels of
感谢我们的赞助商CarShield对本节目的支持。残酷的现实是，许多汽车零件的价格已经上涨了近100%。这意味着当你需要修理汽车时，你可能不仅要支付双倍的零件费，还要支付人工费。有了CarShield，客户就不必担心保修范围内汽车零件的费用。他们的计划最多可涵盖5000个零件和系统。你可以为发动机、变速箱、刹车、空调、电气系统等许多部件获得保障。在某些情况下，可能需要支付免赔额。保障计划起价约为每月100美元，CarShield提供不同级别的
coverage, and most plans include coast-to-coast, roadside assistance, courtesy towing, and car rental options at no extra cost. The best part is CarShield offers price lock guarantee, so your rate will never go up no matter how many claims you file. Protect your wallet from those high costs at a price lock guarantee rate that's locked in for as long as you cover your car. Avoid the hassle of costly car repairs with CarShield. Visit carshield.com slash smartlist and save 20% off today. Again, that's carshield.com slash smartlist to save 20%. Visit carshield.com slash smartlist to lock in your price today.
保障，而且大多数计划都包含全美范围内的道路救援、免费拖车和租车选项，不产生额外费用。最棒的是CarShield提供价格锁定保证，所以无论你提出多少次理赔，你的费率永远不会上涨。用锁定的价格来保护你的钱包免受高昂维修费用的冲击，只要你为汽车投保，这个费率就会一直锁定。通过CarShield避免代价高昂的汽车修理带来的麻烦。访问 carshield.com 斜杠 smartlist，今天就可节省20%。再次强调，访问 carshield.com 斜杠 smartlist 即可节省20%。访问 carshield.com 斜杠 smartlist，今天就锁定您的价格。
Thank you to NutriFall for supporting our show. Get obsession worthy hair, you're no longer obsessing over. NutriFall takes a whole body approach to hair growth, multi-targeting root causes of hair thinning from within, like stress, nutrition, and hormones. With 20-plus vitamins, minerals, and natural ingredients, these 100% drug-free supplements improve hair growth, visible thickness, and strength in a few months.
感谢 NutriFall 对本节目的大力支持。拥有让你不再纠结的、令人着迷的秀发。NutriFall 采用全方位的头发生长方法，从内到有多重针对导致头发变稀疏的根本原因，例如压力、营养和荷尔蒙。凭借20多种维生素、矿物质和天然成分，这些 100% 不含药物的补充剂能在几个月内改善头发生长、明显的厚度和强度。
With NutriFall, building a hair growth routine is simple. Purchase online, no prescription required. Free shipping and automated deliveries ensure you'll never miss a day. Start your hair growth journey with the number one dermatologist recommended hair growth supplement brand. Take the first step towards healthy hair with NutriFall. For a limited time, NutriFall is offering our listeners $10 off your first month subscription and free shipping when you go to nutrifall.com and enter the promo code smartLIS. Find out why over 4,500 healthcare professionals and hair stylists recommend NutraFall for healthier
有了 NutriFall，建立头发生长日常变得很简单。在线购买，无需处方。免费配送和自动配送确保您不会错过任何一天。使用排名第一的皮肤科医生推荐的头发生长补充剂品牌，开启您的头发生长之旅。与 NutriFall 一起迈出迈向健康头发的第一步。限时优惠，访问 nutrifall.com 并输入促销代码 smartLIS，NutriFall 将为您提供首月订阅 10 美元优惠和免费送货服务。了解为什么超过 4,500 名医疗保健专业人士和发型师推荐 NutraFall 以获得更健康的
hair. NutraFall.com spelled N-U-T-R-A-F-O-L.com promo code smartLess. That's NutraFall.com promo code smartLess. And now back to the show. So wait, Sam, I... You guys haven't said anything about my shirt, my T-shirt. I was trying to read it. I couldn't see it and I wasn't sorry that's bad. I am serious and don't call me. Wait, he's wearing tan pants and for a second I thought he was shirt cocking that he just had a shirt. Wait Sam, what is the shirt? Shirt cocking is
头发。NutraFall.com 拼写为 N-U-T-R-A-F-O-L.com，促销代码 smartLess。也就是 NutraFall.com 促销代码 smartLess。现在回到节目中。等等，山姆，我……你们都没说过我的衬衫，我的T恤。我正试图读它。我看不见，我也不感到抱歉，这太糟糕了。我是认真的，别叫我。等等，他穿着棕褐色裤子，有一秒钟我以为他是光着上身只穿着衬衫。等等，山姆，这衬衫是什么？光着上身只穿衬衫是
a real. It's an airplane shirt and it says, I'm serious and don't call me Shirley. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. That's great. That's a great T. I mean, they should redo that movie, right? I mean, there's a whole, not because it needs to be re-released, but just because there's a whole new generation
真的。这是一件飞机衬衫，上面写着：“我是认真的，别叫我雪莉。”哦，对，对，对。太棒了。这是一件很棒的T恤。我的意思是，他们应该重拍那部电影，对吧？我的意思是，有一个全新的，不是因为它需要重新上映，而是因为有一整代人
or three or four now that haven't seen it and that would love. Will's upset. I'm against the reboots. I'm against the reboots all together. Just have to watch the old one, right? I watched the old one and it, maybe it's not as quick or it doesn't cut as fast,
或者现在三四代人没看过它而且会很喜欢。威尔很不高兴。我反对重启。我完全反对重启。只要看旧的就行了，对吧？我看过旧的，而且，也许它没有那么快或者剪辑没有那么快，
but it's good, it's got value. And then let's do some new stuff. Leslie Nielsen. Let's create stuff now that people 20 years will say, let's reboot. You know what I mean? There's so much of the same shit. No, no, no, let me go on a fucking highway.
但它很好，它有价值。然后我们做一些新东西吧。莱斯利·尼尔森。我们现在创造一些东西，让20年后的人们会说，让我们重启吧。你知道我的意思吗？有太多相同的垃圾了。不，不，不，让我上高速公路去吧。
Wait, Sam. By the way, guess who Sam worked with a couple of years ago? You guys are gonna blow both of your minds. Leslie Nielsen. No, it's a, it's a friend of the show. It's in one of the great names of the show. It's one of the all time references of the show. Grimoire Pildrebar.
等等，山姆。顺便说一句，猜猜山姆几年前和谁合作过？你们俩都会大吃一惊。莱斯利·尼尔森。不，这是一个节目的朋友。它是节目的伟大名字之一。它是节目的史上伟大梗之一。格里莫尔·皮尔德巴尔。
That who, he comes up on the show all the time. I talk about him all the time. Chappy. Chappy, Mark Chappell, who wrote See How They Run. Oh. Is, Chappy's one of my best pals and he's my coretter. And must be giving Will at least $10,000 every time his name is mentioned.
那是谁，他总是出现在节目中。我总是谈论他。查比。查比，马克·查佩尔，他写了《看他们如何奔跑》。噢。查比是我最好的朋友之一，也是我的联合编剧。每次提到他的名字，肯定都会给威尔至少1万美元。
Chappy comes up a lot on the, he's a recurring on the show. And he lives in London. Get the scissors out guys. Sean, drive the interview. Yes, thank you. We're not cutting Chappy out. Great script, see you in the run. Yeah, so Moon, when you did Moon, I loved Moon. It's, I mean, it was just you.
查比在节目里经常出现。他是节目的常驻嘉宾。他住在伦敦。把剪刀拿出来，伙计们。肖恩，推进采访。是的，谢谢。我们不会把查比剪掉的。剧本写得真好，演出见。是的，所以当您拍《月球》时，我太喜欢《月球》了。它，我的意思是，只有您自己。
God bless you. I loved that movie so much. Now Duncan Jones knows how to direct, huh? I know. Go back and talk about like, I know we were, it's okay, you can talk about process. That's why we're here. Okay.
上帝保佑您。我太喜欢那部电影了。现在邓肯·琼斯知道怎么导演了，对吧？我知道。回过头来谈谈，我知道我们当时在，没关系，你可以谈谈过程。这就是我们来这里的目的。好的。
I don't want to bore the hell out of it. Cause I'm fascinated how you, what was it like day to day? Did you like the process of being the only person in the movie? Yeah, Tracy, this is a movie where he's the only guy in it and he's stuck on a spaceship. It's stunning. It's stunning. Incredible. It's a really good movie.
我不想把这弄得无聊透顶。因为我很着迷你是怎么，日复一日是什么感觉？你喜欢做电影里唯一一个人的过程吗？是的，特雷西，这是一部只有他一个人、被困在飞船里的电影。太惊艳了。太惊艳了。不可思议。这是一部非常好的电影。
Thank you. Thanks guys. Well, you know, my acting coach, the first thing he says, watch buddy movies. He said, watch Midnight Cowboy I watched. And I stole a lot from Midnight Cowboy. And then, you know, Rachel Weiss just did a reboot of Dead Ringers, which is fucking amazing what she did. And I was watching the Jeremy Irons one. That was the best time, the best version of that trick I had seen. And I listened to the DVD commentary. And there's a very noisy camera called the motion control camera that's used for that gag to get two people in one frame and it's a very
谢谢。谢谢你们。嗯，你知道，我的表演教练，他说的第一件事就是，看搭档电影。他说，去看《午夜牛郎》，我看了。我从《午夜牛郎》里偷了很多东西。然后，你知道，蕾切尔·薇兹刚刚重拍了《孽扣》，太不可思议了，她做得太棒了。我当时在看杰瑞米·艾恩斯的那个版本。那是我看过的那个把戏最好的时代、最好的版本。我听了DVD评论。有一种非常吵闹的摄像机，叫做运动控制摄像机，那个恶作剧用它把两个人拍进一个画面里，这是一个非常
weird process that I could go into and give us a little bit. Well there's a lot about timing the guy the sound guy would put the previous take the master on the on my iPod. And while I was going to hair and makeup for the other one, I would listen to it. So the ping pong scene would be a timing thing. So when I went back to the other clone. So you're acting against yourself.
奇怪的过程，我可以深入讲讲并给我们一点。嗯，这里有很多关于掌握时机的事情，音响师会把之前的镜头，也就是母带，放到我的iPod上。当我去为另一个镜头做发型和化妆时，我会听它。所以乒乓球场景是一个时机问题。所以当我回到另一个克隆人那里时。所以你在跟自己演对手戏。
Acting against yourself. And so I would listen to the sounds. So like if he dropped the handle of the paddle like that, the other clone would retract as he's coming towards him. So I'd have to listen for that. And I know how many beats you have to wait before you speak. Yeah, and he was saying, Doug, he was like,
跟自己演对手戏。所以我就会听那些声音。所以，如果他像那样掉落球拍的手柄，另一个克隆人就会在球拍向他靠近时缩回。所以我必须听那个声音。而且我知道你在说话之前必须等待多少拍。是的，他说，道格，他就像是，
don't add lip, don't add lip. But if you could add lip, if you fit it in the window, right, right, the timing, you know, you can change the line, but it'd have to be that time, you know. And I wonder if today technologically, it would be less antiquated. It's gotta be. Tom Hardy did a good job with it too, and but it's tricky.
不要即兴发挥，不要即兴发挥。但如果你能即兴发挥，如果你能把台词放进窗口里，对，对，时机，你知道的，你可以改台词，但必须在那个时间点，你知道的。我想如果今天从技术上来讲，它就不会那么过时了。一定是的。汤姆·哈迪也做得很好，但这是很棘手的。
It's tricky, but, and it's a lot of work and talking about paying attention, you have to pay attention in a scene as it is, but now you really gotta pay attention because you're also trying to, you know, pick up on timing another thing, did it scratch? Did it scratch an itch in a way that you didn't know?
这很棘手，而且有很多工作，说到专心，你在一个场景中本来就得专心，但现在你真的必须专心，因为你还要努力，你知道的，去把握时机，还有一件事，它挠到痒处了吗？它以一种你不知道的方式挠到痒处了吗？
Was it satisfying on a certain extent? Absolutely, if you're a narcissist and a director, a closeted director, you have control of the scene, obviously, for obvious reasons. And Jeremaritan's talked about contrasting energy. So one twin in Dead Riggers was aggressive and Rachel Weiss did the same thing very well. One was more timid.
在某种程度上它令人满意吗？绝对的，如果你是一个自恋狂和一个导演，一个隐蔽的导演，你对这个场景有控制权，显然，原因很明显。杰瑞·马里顿谈到了对比鲜明的能量。所以《孽扣》中的一个双胞胎是好斗的，蕾切尔·薇兹也把这一点做得很好。另一个比较胆小。
And so we had to do, that was the trick was having contrasting energies. And so one was a clown and one was more together. And yeah, you can control the scene. In fact, we'd have two rehearsals. The AD would go, you know, hey, okay, go to Harry and Megwin. So Mick, you know, we gotta do the other rehearsal. We gotta do the other one.
所以我们必须这样做，秘诀就是拥有对比鲜明的能量。所以一个是小丑，另一个更沉稳。是的，你可以控制这个场景。事实上，我们会排练两次。助理导演会说，你知道，嘿，好吧，去发型和化妆间吧。所以米克，你知道，我们得做另一场排练。我们得做另一场。
So you'd rehearse twice, you know, before you went. Oh wow, yeah. Yeah, so it was a lot. You'd rehearse both sides before. Yeah. Wow. And then I had a body double guy and I was also an actor. And then the other line was coming to you through through the year. Yeah, near week. And sometimes you'd
所以你要排练两次，你知道，在你去之前。噢，哇，是的。是的，所以这很多。你之前把两边都排练了。是的。哇。然后我有一个替身演员，他也是个演员。然后另一句台词是通过耳朵传给你的。是的，在耳边。有时你会
be looking at tennis ball. Sometimes the actor who kind of looks like you from the back. Yeah. You know, so that's a that's a that's a contemplative sort of melancholy dramatic movie. Yes. Do you again, another brain dead question, but do you have a preference about drama versus comedy? I mean. Well, it's funny, you say that because it was a little too serious. And I said, we got to get some jokes in the beginning
看着网球。有时是那个从背面看起来有点像你的演员。是的。你知道，所以那是一部沉思的、某种程度上忧郁的戏剧电影。是的。你再次，又是一个脑残的问题，但你对戏剧和喜剧有什么偏好吗？我的意思是。嗯，有趣的是，你这么说是因为它有点太严肃了。我说，我们得在开头加几个笑话，
because it was so dark. It was like that girl in Poe. And we got some jokes in because we're going to lose the audience because he gets so depressing. Yeah, but then there's that the risk of setting the wrong tone for that which is going to come. That's true.
因为它太黑暗了。就像爱伦·坡笔下的那个女孩。我们加了一些笑话，因为我们要失去观众了，因为它变得太压抑了。是的，但随后就有为接下来要发生的定下错误基调的风险。那倒也是。
So there's a balance there. I remember I was like, I was super precious and annoying and overly sensitive about any sort of. I did it the other night. Any sort of humor going into Ozark. The writers, these great sort of moments of levity in the first season. And I just- Where did you find the compromise eventually?
所以这里面有个平衡。我记得我当时就像，我超级矫情、烦人、对任何形式的……我前几天还这么做过。进入《黑钱胜地》时的任何形式的幽默。编剧们，第一季中这些很棒的轻松时刻。我只是——你最后在哪里找到了妥协？
Well, once we established that, you know, this Jason Bateman show is not going to be a comedy, once the audience knew that after the first season, I felt more comfortable about, you know, making it- Did you watch, serious question, did you watch, after asking them to sort of erase all that, did you watch it, once you got to post where you're like, fuck, I wish there was a moment there?
嗯，一旦我们确定了，你知道的，这个杰森·贝特曼的秀不会是一部喜剧，一旦观众在第一季之后知道了这一点，我对制作它就感到更自适了——你有没有看，严肃的问题，你有没有看，在要求他们擦除所有这些之后，你有没有看它，一旦你到了后期制作，你会觉得，操，我希望那里能有一个时刻？
Did you miss it a little bit? I don't mean a goofy thing, but it was a little bit of contrast. I was too sort of paranoid about being, it being taken seriously in the first year that I didn't worry about that. But the second year I was like, yeah, anyway, sorry, talk about fucking me again.
你有点想念它吗？我不是指滑稽的东西，但它有一点对比。第一年我对被认真对待这件事有点太偏执了，所以我没有担心这个。但第二年我就觉得，好吧，不管怎样，抱歉，又来烦我了。
It's fucking great. Sam, what do we gotta do to have you working? See where you beat the guy up in the car is fucking great. Yeah. But you know, you earned that, you earned that. You know, you just had a lot. Yeah, you fucking earned it.
这太棒了。山姆，我们得做什么才能让你有工作？你看你在车里把那家伙打了一顿，真他妈太棒了。对。但你知道，那是你应得的，那是你应得的。你知道，你付出了很多。是的，你他妈应得的。
What about, how do we get you, how do we get you working 12 months a year so I as a Sam Rockwell fan can have more to enjoy? That's a great, yes. I think I have to, because you're balancing theater and film, so I gotta go to New York to see you sometimes, right? Which I'm coming, I'm coming this weekend for seven months.
那怎样才能让我们，怎样才能让你一年工作12个月，好让我作为一个山姆·罗克韦尔的粉丝能有更多享受？太棒了，是的。我想我必须这样做，因为你在平衡戏剧和电影，所以我有时得去纽约看你，对吧？我来，我这周末要来七个月。
So get ready. Okay, we're gonna do some hanging. It's a throw, we're all waiting some hanging. It's a throwing crew, we're all waiting. So wait, Sam, we're talking about all these kind of prep things for roles in different movies. Do you have a thing that you first do when you either walk on a set or prepare for a character? Do you have like a go-to, any kind of superstition thing,
所以准备好吧。好的，我们要一起聚聚。这是一群人，我们都在等待。所以等等，山姆，我们在谈论所有这些针对不同电影中角色的准备工作。当你走进片场或为角色做准备时，你有什么首先要做的事情吗？你有什么必备的、任何形式的迷信做法吗，
like we do in theater? No, it all comes out of fear, trying to memorize the script and panic and, you know, and then you go to a, go see my coach, Tara Nickerbocker, where I go, and sometimes you have time to do research, sometimes you don't, and you might have the luxury of a few months and then you would do research,
就像我们在剧院里做的那样？不，这一切都源于恐惧，试图记住剧本和恐慌，你知道，然后你去看，去看我的教练塔拉·尼克博克，我去那里，有时你有时间做研究，有时你没有，你可能有几个月的奢侈时间，然后你会做研究，
like three billboards or something, I did research, but like, you don't always have the time to do that. So you're kind of like, just like, all right, I'm an arms dealer. All right, okay, fuck. I'm gonna watch Bill Murray and Kingpin. That's it, that's my research. Yeah, yeah, that's the actual.
比如《三块广告牌》之类的，我做了研究，但就像，你并不总是有时间这样做。所以你有点像，好吧，我是个军火商。好吧，好吧，操。我要去看比尔·默瑞的《保龄球尤物》。就这样，这就是我的研究。对，对，这就是现实。
But are you like Billy, because Billy talks about it and you know, you guys know it, like Billy likes to spend time with the dialogue for weeks. Yeah, yeah. Did you see the one man show he did? Jesus Christ. No, I missed it.
但你像比利吗，因为比利谈过这个，你们也都知道，就像比利喜欢花几周时间琢磨台词。对，对。你看过他演的那个独角秀吗？天哪。没有，我错过了。
But are you good at learning your lines? Are you quick with that? No, terrible. I need time. Really? I need a lot of time, yeah. I need a lot of time. Have you always been terrible?
但你擅长记台词吗？你在这方面很快吗？不，太糟糕了。我需要时间。真的吗？我需要很多时间，是的。我需要很多时间。你一直都很糟糕吗？
I mean, I tape the monotone. That's a Meisner thing, but I tape him and I run him with a reader, an actor. I think Billy does a similar thing. Billy's smarter than me though. He knows how to, he really breaks his shit down. My partner does too, Leslie. Her script is like really organized.
我的意思是，我把单调的声音录下来。那是梅斯纳的方法，但我把它们录下来，然后和一个读词人、一个演员一起对台词。我想比利也做类似的事情。不过比利比我聪明。他知道如何，他真的把剧本剖析得很透彻。我的伴侣也是，莱斯莉。她的剧本组织得非常好。
Mine looks like a kindergarten grown up. I'm always fearful that I'm gonna, if I really, really work on it, and I do a bunch of research and all that stuff, that I'll end up acting. That all of that is to do the greatest acting job ever. As opposed to, but that's my own bullshit. You put work in, come on.
我的看起来像幼儿园小孩涂鸦的。我总是害怕，如果我真的、真的努力去琢磨它，做了很多研究和所有这些事情，我最终会变成在“演戏”。所有这一切都是为了做出有史以来最伟大的表演。而不是，但这是我自己的胡扯。你付出了努力，拜托。
I do put a lot of work into it, but there's a list of techniques and homework stuff that I used to do when I was a kid and went to acting classes and stuff like that. And I found that I was so proud of the work that I had done that I was hell bent on making sure the audience saw that work. I understand that.
我确实付出了很多努力，但有一张技术和家庭作业清单，那是我小时候去表演班之类的东西时做的。我发现我对自己的劳动成果如此骄傲，以至于我一门心思要确保观众看到那个劳动成果。我理解。
Yeah, I mean, I don't like backstory. That's the thing I don't really care about. Yeah. I don't, I think that's useful. Interesting, but it's important for some actors. Everyone's got a different thing. I mean, it doesn't I think interesting but it's important for some actors everyone's Yeah, yeah, I you know, I think it depends you know It depends if it makes an imprint on you
是的，我的意思是，我不喜欢背景故事。那是真的一点都不在乎的东西。对。我不知道，我认为那很有用。有趣，但对某些演员来说很重要。每个人都有不同的情况。我的意思是，这没有，我认为有趣但对某些演员很重要，每个人都有是的，是的，你知道，我认为这取决于，你知道。这取决于它是否对你产生了印记。
You know you can get an ad lib from from somebody a real person. Do you ever get a? I was gonna ask you Sean get into like sort of the difference and with you Sammy as well about Then when you're working on stage, then you have the sort of the luxury of time to work on that and you understand and you have a facility with the dialogue because you've been working on it for months. But before I get into that, have you ever had the thing
你知道，你可以从某人、一个真人那里得到即兴台词。你曾经得到过吗？我正要问你，肖恩，关于你和萨米以及你在舞台上工作时的不同之处，然后你就有时间去处理它，你理解它，而且你对台词很熟悉，因为你已经琢磨了几个月。但在我谈到这个之前，你有没有遇到过这样的情况：
where I've had a couple of times where like a member of the crew will go, well like between takes to go, hey, you know what I thought it'd be really funny if you said, and I go, what's that now? Like pitching me a joke or like a different way to say a joke and I'm like, what up? And then, and it's not bad. And they go like, I just thought it'd be really funny
我有过几次，比如剧组里的一员会说，嗯，比如在拍片间隙说，嘿，你知道我觉得如果你这么说会很有趣，然后我说，你说什么呢？就像向我推销一个笑话或者说笑话的不同方式，然后我说，什么鬼？然后，这并不糟糕。他们说，我只是觉得如果你这样说会非常有趣。
if you said this. I'm like, oh yeah, okay, man. Well, I thought it'd be really funny if you move the fucking C stand over there. You know what I mean? But what if it's a good idea, you dick? No, I'm kidding, I'm being a fuck. Actually, it should be,
我说，哦，好吧，好吧，老兄。好吧，我觉得如果你把那个他妈的C形灯架搬到那边去会更有趣。你知道我的意思吗？但如果是个好主意呢，你个混蛋？不，我开玩笑呢，我真是个混蛋。其实应该是，
I'm just saying that just to be funny. The truth is, I've actually had some pretty good pitches before from like, you know, dudes. And there was a boom operator that I knew, this guy, Tom, who was really fucking funny. Jay, do you remember that dude, Tom? Yeah. And he was super funny and every once in a while,
我这么说只是为了搞笑。事实是，我实际上以前从一些（你知道的）家伙那里得到过一些相当不错的推销。我认识一个叫汤姆的 boom 录音师，他他妈的超级搞笑。杰伊，你还记得那个叫汤姆的家伙吗？对。他超级搞笑，每隔一段时间，
like between takes, he'd go like, hey, you know what, blah, blah, blah. And I go, fuck, that's fucking great. And I'd use it. I'd say, thank you. Give him a little wink while he's holding it. I know if an actor does it. You know, what if another actor does it?
比如在镜头之间，他会说，嘿，你知道的，巴拉巴拉巴拉。然后我说，操，这太他妈棒了。我就会用它。我会说，谢谢。在他拿着话筒的时候给他使个眼色。我知道如果演员这么做的话。你知道，如果另一个演员这么做呢？
And then you're like, hey. Fuck, that's a fight. I'm always like best, best, whatever. That, yeah. If it works, it works. I don't mind that. I never mind a line reading from a director either because you're always gonna make it your own.
然后你会觉得，嘿。操，那是一场架。我总是觉得最好，最好，随便吧。那个，对。如果管用，就管用。我不介意这个。我从不介意导演教戏，因为你总是能把它变成你自己的。
No, but you know what, there is that thing, and I will not say who this is, but there are things before where an actor might say to you, like, hey, you know what'd be really great? Say this, and they'll say it in rehearsal, and they'll say it to the director as you're doing a rehearsal. So at that point, you go like,
不，但你知道吗，确实有那种事，我不会说这是谁，但以前有过这样的事情，一个演员可能会对你说，嘿，你知道什么会特别好吗？说这个，他们会在排练时说，而且在排练时也会对导演说。所以在那个时候，你会觉得，
everybody's kind of waiting for me to do his pitch. That he said out loud to the director. You do it and then they laugh. I see, isn't that amazing? And you're so embarrassed. Well, that brings me to my, my thing about directing is I think, I was thinking, Jason, I don't know what you do with actors,
每个人都在等着我按照他的提议来演。他大声对导演说的。你照做了，然后他们笑了。我明白了，这不是很神奇吗？而你却如此尴尬。嗯，这让我想到了我，我对导演的看法是，我在想，杰森，我不知道你是怎么对演员的，
but I feel like you're really good with actors., I don't know what you do with actors, but I feel like you're really good with actors. But I don't know when a director screams a direction across a long distance, you know, over the crew, it's kind of telling the whole crew that the rabbit's going to come out of the hat before it does. And then you're like, hey man, there's a lot of pressure to take the rabbit out of that. You know what I mean? Right. Right, right. And then you end up adjusting your reading to make it surprising for the crew when it's not really the reading
但我觉得你对演员真的很好。，我不知道你是怎么对演员的，但我觉得你对演员真的很好。但我不知道当一个导演隔着很远的距离大声喊出指导意见时（你知道，越过剧组），这有点像在兔子从帽子里跳出来之前就把这件事告诉了整个剧组。然后你就会想，嘿，老兄，要把兔子从帽子里拿出来压力很大。你知道我的意思吗？对。对，对。然后你最终会调整你的表演，让它对剧组来说感到惊讶，而这并不是真正适合家里观众的表演。
that would be right for the audience at home. Yeah, I kind of want a conspiracy with the director. Yeah, I love it. I love the secret. Yeah, whispering, yeah. Sam, what do you do when all of this is, when we're not talking about this and you're not doing this, what do you do?
是的，我有点想和导演达成某种共识。是的，我喜欢。我喜欢这个秘密。是的，耳语，对。山姆，当这一切结束，当我们不谈论这个而你也不做这个的时候，你做些什么？
Yeah, what's the hobby? What would our listeners be excited to learn that you do? Well, somebody, I think maybe Thoreau just told me, potato chips are not a protein, which is alarming. I was during the pandemic, I got into some potato chips. Now, you know, I overwork out and then I over eat, blah, blah, blah, blah, you know, I do it.
是的，有什么爱好？我们的听众会因为了解到你做这个而感到兴奋吗？嗯，有人，我想也许梭罗刚刚告诉我，薯片不是蛋白质，这真令人担忧。大流行期间，我迷上了薯片。现在，你知道，我过度锻炼然后又暴饮暴食，巴拉巴拉巴拉，你知道，我就是这样。
That's what I'm kind of compulsive. What's your exercise of choice? Are you a jogger? Everything. Like I might hit hot yoga or I might, the weights or I got the, the SoulCycle here, hit the mids, you know, that kind of shit. And that's all to facilitate your snacking.
我有点强迫症。你首选的锻炼方式是什么？你是个慢跑者吗？什么都做。比如我可能会去练热瑜伽，或者我可能会举重，或者我有这里的 SoulCycle（动感单车），练练核心，你知道，那类破事。这一切都是为了促进你的零食消化。
All to facilitate, yes. That's why I work out. A little bit of, a little IPA, a little potato chips and chocolate. Well, you do a little, you do a little bit of boxing, right? You do a little bit of boxing. I've been doing, throw Gummy into like doing
全是为了促进消化，是的。这就是我锻炼的原因。来点，来点IPA（印度淡艾尔），来点薯片和巧克力。嗯，你做，你做一点拳击，对吧？你做一点拳击。我一直在做，把加米（Gummy）也拉进来了，比如做
the SoulCycle of boxing. You know, it's the- Oh yeah, my friend does that. Fight camp, right? And by the way, got me in shape. But now my son, what's interesting is my son, my oldest son who's 15, Archie, because I started doing that, he got into it because of Thoreau, through somebody else.
拳击版的 SoulCycle。你知道那是——哦，对，我朋友也做那个。格斗训练营，对吧？顺便说一句，让我保持了身材。但现在我的儿子，有趣的是我的儿子，我的大儿子阿奇（Archie）15岁了，因为我开始做那个，他在梭罗的影响下，通过其他人也迷上了。
Anyway, he starts to, now he's fighting with a real guy in a gym every weekend, which is crazy. Oh, he's sparring. Your son's sparring. So he's sparring and he's really getting into it. He's way better than me. Oh shit, don't be careful. So I know.
不管怎样，他开始，现在他每个周末都在健身房跟一个真正的家伙打拳，这太疯狂了。哦，他在实战训练。你儿子在实战训练。所以他在实战训练，而且他真的很投入。他比我强多了。哦，操，小心点。所以，我知道。
Well, I'm very excited to see our guy. Should I be? Yes. Yeah, I saw the trailer. It looks incredible and I love Matthew Vaughn. It's really fun. That looks like a blast to shoot a movie like that. I'm very jealous.
嗯，我很高兴看到我们的伙计。我应该吗？对。是的，我看了预告片。看起来不可思议，而且我很喜欢马修·沃恩。真的很有趣。拍一部那样的电影看起来一定超爽。我很嫉妒。
A whole movie about a sweater. Yeah. So it starts with the idea, then the knitting, and then someone wears it. That looks like a blast to shoot a movie like that. A whole movie about a sweater. Yeah. So it starts with the idea, then the knitting, and then someone wears it. Walk me through it. You just gave away the ending. That's right. No, it's a lot of fun. You guys all hit your head so that the doctor is...
整部电影都在讲一件毛衣。对。所以它从一个创意开始，然后是织毛衣，然后有人把它穿上。拍一部那样的电影看起来一定超爽。整部电影都在讲一件毛衣。对。所以它从一个创意开始，然后是织毛衣，然后有人把它穿上。带我了解一下。你刚刚剧透了结局。没错。不，这真的很有趣。你们都撞到了头，所以那个医生……
Do you like doing all the action stuff and the stunts and things like that? Did you get hurt at all? You must have. No, we had an amazing stunt team. He's agile, dude. He's fucking looking at me. Yeah's agile. Yeah, but you gotta do the start of the stunt and the end of the stunt, right? Yeah, do a little bit of the kung fu fighting, yeah. Yeah, and you had fun with that. I like it, it's fun.
你喜欢做所有的动作戏、特技和诸如此类的事情吗？你受伤了吗？你肯定受过伤。不，我们有一个了不起的特技团队。他很敏捷，老兄。他他妈的看着我。对，很敏捷。对，但你得做特技的开头和特技的结尾，对吧？对，做一点功夫打斗，对。是的，你玩得很开心。我喜欢，这很有趣。
I like it, the fake stylized violence, but you know, I had an amazing stunt double. Every time I would do something, I thought I was going fast and then I'd watch him and then I looked like I was in slow motion. Is this a stunt double you've worked with before? He's amazing, no. He's a prodigy.
我喜欢，虚构的风格化暴力，但你知道，我有一个了不起的特技替身。每次我做点什么，我以为自己动作挺快，然后我看着他，接着我就觉得自己像是在慢动作。这是你以前合作过的特技替身吗？他太棒了，不是。他是个天才。
Same's Greg Talley. He's like a Jackie Chan. He's from Northern England. He's a gymnast. He's a double for Spiderman. He's 26. He was 24 when he did mine. Yeah, he's amazing.
山姆的是格雷格·塔利（Greg Talley）。他就像个成龙。他来自英格兰北部。他是体操运动员。他是蜘蛛侠的替身。他26岁。他做我的替身时24岁。是的，他太棒了。
Did he get hurt? He did get hurt on another thing, but he's fine. Okay, very good. He's fine, yeah, yeah. Do you ever get, have you ever get hurt on another thing, but he's fine. Okay. He's fine, yeah, yeah. Have you ever gotten hurt or hurt somebody doing a scene? No, Tim Roth and I kinda hit each other, kinda clipped each other in a rain machine doing a fight, but it was fine, nothing serious.
他受伤了吗？他在另一部戏里受过伤，但他没事。好的，很好。他没事，对，对。你有没有，你有没有在另一部戏里受过伤，但他没事？好吧。他没事，对，对。你在拍戏时受过伤或者弄伤过别人吗？没有，蒂姆·罗斯和我有点撞到对方了，在雨景里拍打斗戏时有点擦到对方，但没关系，没什么严重的。
Was that on holiday or during a shoot? I broke my toe talking to my agent in my house once. You know what I mean? That's what I mean. Yeah, that's the bad thing. I once sprained my finger getting into a Tesla. Yeah. You know what?
那是度假时还是拍摄期间？我有一次在我家跟经纪人说话时把脚趾给弄骨折了。你知道我的意思吗？这就是我的意思。对，这就是糟糕的地方。我曾经在进特斯拉时扭伤了手指。你知道吗？
Sam, we took up way too much of your time. Wait, wait, I want to ask you about Oscar though. How did you get ready for that? How did you do that? How did you, what was your research for that? Well, it took a G5 to New York and then, and then it escalated from Teterboro to the Upper West Side, I think.
山姆，我们占用了你太多时间了。等等，等等，不过我想问你关于奥斯卡的事。你是怎么为那个做准备的？你是怎么做到的？你是怎么，你对那个做了什么研究？嗯，坐G5去了纽约，然后，然后从铁特伯勒（Teterboro）升级到了上西区，我想。
You really, but you nailed that guy. What, I mean, that's a lot of, that's a lot of behavior, man. That's a lot of, it's a whole thing with the imitate. Forget about the piano. It's a long, long story and it took about 20 years. Does it involve scooping up bagels from Zabars and filling them with peanut butter? Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha And there was, I've said this story on here before. And one of the reviews in Chicago where we opened it said, Sean's gonna be great on Broadway,
你真的，但你把那个家伙演绝了。什么，我的意思是，那有很多，那有很多行为举止，老兄。那有很多，那是关于模仿的整套东西。别提钢琴了。这是一个很长很长的故事，花了大约20年。这包括从扎巴尔（Zabars）买百吉饼并把它们填满花生酱吗？哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
but he needs to kill the fat suit and the plastic wig. No. Both my body and my hair. Yeah, you weren't wearing a wig or a fat suit, is that right? No, Sean. No, Seany. But anyway, thanks for asking, Sam, this very sweet.
而且还有，我在节目里说过这个故事。我们在芝加哥开幕时的其中一篇评论说，肖恩在百老汇会很棒，
Well, I'd like to hear more. But we didn't even get to be handing in Spokane or like, you know, billboards, which you won the Oscar for, which I fucking blew my mind. You blew my mind in that. There's so much to talk to. I will say, there are very few people.
但他需要去掉胖人服装和塑料假发。不。我的身材和头发。是的，你没有戴假发或穿胖人服装，对吧？不，肖恩。不，肖尼。不管怎样，谢谢你问，山姆，这太贴心了。
There are a lot of people, no, sorry, that's not true. I will say a lot of people are deserving of Oscars all the time, every year. But to see you win an Oscar was so cool. You deserve 10 of them. So fucking cool. I love you guys. You're so fucking deserving.
嗯，我还想听更多。但我们甚至都没谈到《精神玩家》或像，你知道的，让你赢得奥斯卡的《三块广告牌》，那把我他妈的震撼到了。你在那里的表演把我震撼到了。有太多话要说了。我要说的是，极少有人。
You're so talented. And really quick, when I was doing, you were doing Behanding and Spokane while I was doing promises, promises. And I went downstairs to the basement to get my haircut from a woman named, I think her name's Carmel. And I walked down, getting ready for my weekly
有很多，不，抱歉，那不是真的。我要说的是，有很多演员每年都当之无愧地赢得奥斯卡。但看到你赢得奥斯卡真是太酷了。你配得上其中10座。太他妈酷了。我爱你们。你们太他妈实至名归了。
or two bi-weekly haircut, and there you are, sitting in the chair. And I was like, holy shit, that's fucking Sam Rockwell. Yeah. What's he doing here? I'm like, why did he come here to get his haircut? I just thought that was the coolest thing in the world. Like I was guffawing.
你们太有才了。顺便说一句，当我在演，你在演《精神玩家》的时候，我正在演《承诺，承诺》。我走到地下室去剪头发，一个女人，我想她叫卡梅尔（Carmel）。我走下去，准备迎接我每周
I'm just a parasite. Yeah, listener, if you're not in the entertainment industry you need to know that this guy is the guy Everybody wants to work with be friends with he does Constantly the best performances. It's just always it's just catnip for actors and the fact that we're able to even call ourselves Friends with him is is enormous. So yeah, you deserve multiple statues. Yeah. And I want more. You need to get a Thalberg right now.
或每两周一次的理发，结果你就在那儿，坐在椅子上。当时我就想，天哪，那他妈的是山姆·罗克韦尔。对。他在那儿干嘛？我就想，他为什么来这儿理发？我当时觉得那是世界上最酷的事。我笑得前仰后合。
You need to get a full, like the full, you know what I'm saying? Right? We're gonna give the smart list Thalberg. Let's do that. Listen, I love you guys. I love this podcast. I'm a true, true fan. I know the terminology.
我只是个寄生虫。是的，听众朋友，如果你不在娱乐行业，你需要知道这家伙就是那种每个人都想跟他合作、跟他做朋友的人。他总是奉献出最棒的表演。对演员来说这简直就是猫薄荷，我们甚至能称自己是他的朋友，这简直太了不起了。所以，是的，你配得上多座小金人。是的。而且我想要更多。你现在就得拿个欧文·撒尔伯格奖。
I'm a, anyway, fan. I know the terminology. I love you guys. Love you too, Sam. Thanks for being here today. Can't wait to see you soon. And the beard looks fantastic. Thanks guys. You look amazing. You look amazing. Thanks for doing this dude. God.
你得拿一个完整的，就像完整的，你知道我在说什么吗？对不对？我们要把智能榜单的撒尔伯格奖颁给你。我们这么做吧。听着，我爱你们。我爱这个播客。我是个彻头彻尾的真爱粉。我懂专业术语。
Thank you for having me. Thank you for having me. And let's give Theroc, endless shit. Oh yeah, please. I mean, you can't hurt him more than he hurts himself. You know, let's be honest. All right. Big fat love. All right. Big fat love. Thanks guys. Peace out. Thanks buddy. Peace out. Bye Sammy. Bye. Oh, Sam the Rock. Shawty, great. Great. I love him so much. He's such a good guy too. He's just the greatest.
我是一个，不管怎样，粉丝。我懂专业术语。我爱你们。我也爱你，山姆。谢谢你今天来到这里。迫不及待想很快见到你。而且胡子看起来棒极了。谢谢你们，伙计们。你们看起来太棒了。你们看起来太棒了。谢谢你做这些，老兄。天哪。
You know, you know, well, I sound like a broken record. He's just the greatest, you know? Yeah. Well, I sound like a broken record, but I truly do. But you know, when you go like, like, well, when you were saying, you go through all of it, when I was researching him and knowing he was coming out of the day, you go through all of his films and his projects, you're like, bam, bam, bam, bam, hit after hit. And if they weren't like a massive hit, he was great and like you said, he was great in it. It's just, you know, it's the result of dedicating your life like he has to a craft or an art or anything.
谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢你们邀请我。让我们去折腾一下梭罗吧。哦，对，拜托。我的意思是，你伤害他不会比他伤害自己更深。你知道，说实话。好吧。满满的爱。好吧。满满的爱。谢谢你们，伙计们。拜拜。谢谢老兄。拜拜。再见，萨米。再见。哦，山姆·罗克。肖蒂，太棒了。太棒了。我太喜欢他了。他真的是个好人。他简直是最棒的。
He's also walking down. He's just like no matter what part he's playing, even if it's, you know, sort of just like, you know, the lead that's kind of just kind of the straight guy, he'll find a way to give that character some quirk, something interesting. There's a little bit of like sparkle to- Color, the little shades.
你知道，你知道，嗯，我听起来像张破唱片。他简直是最棒的，你知道吗？是的。嗯，我听起来像张破唱片，但我确实是这么想的。但你知道，当你去，比如，嗯，当你这么说时，你经历这一切，当我研究他并知道他那天要来时，你回顾他所有的电影和项目，你会觉得，棒，棒，棒，棒，一部接一部的大热作品。即使它们不是那种大卖的爆款，他也演得很棒，就像你说的，他在里面表现得很出色。这只是，你知道，这是你把一生奉献给你所热爱的手艺、艺术或任何东西的结果。
It's easy to overdo that and overplay a character because it might not be written in the character, but he finds the right spots to do it. Yeah, you know, I was gonna say, I've always sort of used, John Goodman is my example of the person who's amazing in everything he does, no matter what the thing is over time, right?
他也一直在走下坡路。他只是不管扮演什么角色，哪怕只是，你知道，那种有点像，你知道，那种比较正统的主角，他也会想办法给那个角色注入一些古怪、有趣的东西。有一点点那种闪光点——色彩，细微的差别。
And different volumes, different tones, dramas, comedies, Sam's in that same category and always good. He's in that like dramas, comedies, things. And like you say, Jay, like just adds color, has a little something, brings a little sparkle. Like it's the career that you wish you, I wish I had. Of course. But I want him to be cast in leads, you know, as well as just like the...
很容易做得过头、把角色演过火，因为剧本里可能没有写出来，但他找到了做这件事的正确切入点。是的，你知道，我正要说，我一直把约翰·古德曼当作我的例子，他是那种在任何他参演的东西里都表现得极其出色的演员，不管那是什么作品，随着时间的推移，对吧？
Well, but it's not as often as they... I mean, I've, he and I have talked about this, like there's just, there's a, you know, there's a certain kind of sort of like sort of like an average type of look and person and presence that studios feel comfortable with putting as the lead. They don't want anybody too definitive or specific. Well, that's because they're worried about, because they sort of think, they're always trying to anticipate what they think,
而且不同的体量，不同的基调，戏剧，喜剧，山姆也属于那一类，而且总是表现出色。他就属于那种戏剧、喜剧之类的范畴。就像你说的，杰伊，就是增加色彩，有一点特色，带有一点闪光点。就像那是你梦寐以求的职业生涯，我希望我能有。当然。但我希望他能被选为主角，你知道，而不仅仅是……
audiences, and they think about sort of economics. They're like, what is the thing, the prototypical? Yeah, but he can play something completely normal and level and just at the moments where it's appropriate for the leaps and... But he's almost like too interesting in a way. And I mean that as a compliment, not too weird. Too, he's got so much personality, he's super smart,
嗯，但这并不像他们经常……我的意思是，我和他谈过这个，就像有一个，你知道，有一种某种，某种通常的外表、类型、个人和气质，是制片厂觉得作为主角会感到舒适的。他们不希望任何人太有定义或太具体。嗯，那是因为他们担心，因为他们有点认为，他们总是在试图预测他们所认为的，
he's super fucking cool. He's magnetic on screen. We joked about Chappie, you should see how they run. It's a really good move. He's so interesting in that as this, he's the lead, he's the detective who's got all this shit going on. He's fucking, you're like, fuck man,
观众的想法，他们考虑经济效益。他们会觉得，什么是那种典型？是的，但完全可以扮演正常、平和、恰好在适合大爆发和……的时刻。但某种程度上他又太有趣了。我是当作赞美来说的，不是说太怪异。太，他太有个性了，他超级聪明，
this guy's just, he always brings it, always brings it. By it by the way Iron Man 2 we didn't talk about Iron Man 2 written by written by the Justin Thoreau Justin Thoreau that's right yeah that's he wrote so hard that's when the first time the sleeves came off because he was writing yeah and they said it smoked him off yeah it was it was a fire right it was a fire, right? It was a fire It was a wrist fire that worked his way up Hey, yeah, well, I don't know what you're doing later, but are you open to throwing me? Oh Sure, can you just throw me please?
他超级他妈的酷。他在银幕上具有磁性。我们刚才开玩笑说到查比，你们应该去看看《看他们如何奔跑》。那是一部非常好的电影。他在里面作为主角表现得太有趣了，他是那个有着一堆烂摊子要处理的侦探。他他妈的，你会觉得，操，老兄，
Sure, man. You want to be careful though You don't want to break break your arm and if you do break your arm you want to break it around the forearm You don't want to break your arm and if you do break your arm you want to break it around the forearm you don't want to break it up near the b-bye! Bye! Smart. Right. Smart. Right. Smart.
这家伙简直，他总是全力以赴，总是全力以赴。顺便说一句，《钢铁侠2》，我们没聊《钢铁侠2》，编剧是，编剧是贾斯汀·塞洛克斯。贾斯汀·塞洛克斯，没错，是的，那是他写的，太卖力了，那就是袖子第一次撸起来的时候，因为他在写作，是的，他们说这把他累坏了，是的，那是一场火，对吧？那是一场大火。那是一场手腕上的大火，一直蔓延到手臂。嘿，好吧，我不知道你待会儿要干嘛，但你愿意把我扔出去吗？哦，当然，你能把我扔出去吗，求你了？
Right. Smart. Right. Smart. Right. Smart. Right. Smart.
当然，老兄。不过你得小心点。你可不想摔断胳膊，如果你真的摔断了胳膊，你想把它摔在小臂附近。你可不想摔断胳膊，如果你真的摔断了胳膊，你想把它摔在小臂附近，你可不想在上臂二头肌附近摔断它！拜拜！
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbicot, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjalf. SmartLess If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad-free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen ad-free on Amazon Music.
聪明。对。聪明。对。聪明。对。聪明。对。聪明。对。聪明。对。聪明。
Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com. Academy is a new scripted podcast that follows Ava Richards, played by HBO's industries Myhalla Harald, a brilliant scholarship student who has to quickly adapt to her newfound eat-or-be-eaten world. Ava's ambitions take hold and her small town values break in hopes of becoming the first scholarship student to make the list. Bishop Gray is all coveted academic top 10
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。SmartLess 由 Bennett Barbicot、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob Armjalf 100% 有机手工制作。SmartLess 如果您喜欢 SmartLess，现在可以通过加入 Wondery App 或 Apple Podcasts 上的 Wondery Plus，抢先收听无广告版。Prime 会员可以在 Amazon Music 上收听无广告版。
curated by the headmaster himself. But after realizing she has no chance at the list on her own, she reluctantly accepts an invitation to a secret underground society that pulls the strings on campus life and academic success. If she bends to their will, she'll have everything she's ever dreamed of. But at what cost? Academy takes you into the world of a cutthroat private school where power, money, and sex collide in a game of life and death.
在您离开之前，请在 Wondry.com 上填写一份简短的调查问卷，告诉我们您的信息。《学院》（Academy）是一部全新的剧本播客，讲述了 HBO 剧集《行业》中的迈哈拉·哈罗德（Myha'la Herrold）饰演的艾娃·理查兹（Ava Richards）的故事，她是一名才华横溢的奖学金学生，必须迅速适应她新发现的弱肉强食的世界。艾娃的野心开始萌芽，为了成为第一个挤进榜单的奖学金学生，她打破了小镇价值观。主教格雷（Bishop Gray）是梦寐以求的学术前十名，
Follow Academy on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can binge all episodes of Academy early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由校长亲自评选。但在意识到自己凭一己之力毫无机会上榜后，她勉强接受了一个秘密地下社团的邀请，该社团操纵着校园生活和学业成功。如果她屈服于他们的意愿，她将拥有一切梦寐以求的东西。但代价是什么？《学院》将带你进入一个残酷的私立学校世界，权力和金钱、性在一个生死游戏中交织碰撞。在 Wondery App 或您获取播客的任何地方关注《学院》。通过加入 Wondery Plus，您可以现在就抢先且无广告地狂看《学院》的所有剧集。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。